this is Jocko podcast number 383 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
Ambush Wright Ambush right someone
screamed
from the high Bush on my right the sound
of blank fire erupted in a deafening
Roar the Ambush was on simultaneously
all the men in the platoon dropped to
the ground and returned fire into the
Tall Grass grenade grenade another voice
shouted out to my immediate left just to
the side just to the side of the point
man a grenade simulator exploded first
one then another booming in my ears with
stunning effect on the ground around me
my platoon continued to fire changing
magazines and waiting for me to give the
order to move we couldn't counter-attack
through the brush brush it was too thick
we couldn't move to the right the
instructors had sealed off our exit it
appeared our only choice was to move
left and try and get out of the Kill
Zone in my mind I knew that was the
textbook answer but I had a better idea
without hesitation I jacked another
magazine into my M16 jumped up for my
prone position and ran around the left
edge of the heavy brush nodding to the
point man as I bolted past him I would
flank the instructor's circle around the
bushes come up from behind them and
counter Ambush them myself this was
going to be awesome
like a man possessed I charged past the
row of bushes jumped over a few small
Boulders and found myself unopposed on
The High Ground behind the instructors
flipping my selector switch to full auto
I pulled the trigger and raked the
bodies of the seven men lying behind the
high brush I moved forward continuing to
fire as I methodically shot each man
with blank ammunition we had won
what the hell are you doing Mr Mac
instructor faculty yelled jumping up
from the ground killing the bad guys was
my quick and proud retort doc Jennings
one of the few black frogmen of the
Vietnam era stood up from where he was
lying and gave me a complete look of
disdain
sir you're a damn fool he said or words
to those effect
you left your platoon lying in the Kill
Zone did they know what you were doing
somehow this wasn't going as I had
imagined get back with your platoon Mr
Mac Jennings said sternly I thought the
worst of my ass chewing was over surely
the platoon would appreciate my quick
thinking they would understand what I
was trying to do I had defeated the
instructors that must count for
something
sir what the hell were you thinking
Varner said echoing the words of Faculty
we had no idea where you went LeBlanc
piped in I quickly tried to explain look
guys I saw an opportunity to flank the
enemy and save the platoon I reacted
well sir that's just fine but we had no
clue what you were doing or where you
were going Marshall Lubin had swung
around to join in the conversation yeah
man I thought you were running away from
the firefight no no no come on guys I
was trying to save the platoon
Sir with all due respect Varner said a
little less caustic now your job was to
get us out of the Kill Zone to
communicate your intent so we could all
move together and survive
I just nodded I knew they were right Jim
Varner's words stayed with me for the
rest of my career your job was to get us
out of the Kill Zone to communicate your
intent so we could all move together and
survive
and that right there is an excerpt from
a new book that is out that is called
the wisdom of the bullfrog which was
written by Admiral William H mcraven
Admiral mcraven spent 37 years as an
active duty seal officer
becoming eventually the commander of the
United States Special Operations Command
four-star Admiral in charge of All
American Special Operations forces he
oversaw
thousands and thousands of missions
during the global war on terror
including
organizing and overseeing operation
Neptune's spear The Raid that led to the
killing of Osama bin Laden and he has
been on this podcast before
episode 290. if you haven't listened to
it go listen to it it's just outstanding
to hear to hear his stories he's written
a bunch of books
a book called spec ops case studies in
Special Operations theory and practice
a book called make your bed little
things that can change your life and
maybe the world a book called see
stories my life in Special Operations a
book called The Hero code Lessons
Learned From lives well lived and
finally and most recently this book The
Wisdom of the bullfrog leadership made
simple but not easy
and that is where that opening came from
from a training mission
and that one kind of cracked me up and I
heard you laughing as I was reading it
too sir uh it's an honor to have you
here uh once again to talk about some of
your Lessons Learned in your life and
and pass on some of that wisdom from the
bullfrog yeah always good to be right
there yeah I so I ran training for the
West Coast for the last three years I
was in and I got to see so many young
Lieutenant rambos get up and decide to
seem like a good idea at the time you
know he did uh the bullfrog I we we
touched on it last time we were on but
tell us what the bullfrog is yeah so the
bullfrog as you know Jocko is the title
given to the longest serving Navy SEAL
on active duty and for your listeners of
course as Navy Seals we are first and
foremost maybe frogmen so when you are
the senior frog man you are the bullfrog
but what a lot of people don't know is
when you become the bullfrog they give
you this god-awful trophy uh and I think
a little bit of us to make sure you
don't get too follow yourself so the
trophy looks like it was made at some
you know Dime Store but it's got a big
Toad on top of it you know it's not some
Grand bullfrog it's a toad so it's like
okay brother yay you've served longer
than anybody else but that doesn't mean
a whole lot you know other than the fact
you've been around for a while
um yeah that that's uh definitely we
always kind of knew who the bullfrog was
at any given time in the SEAL Teams
um I actually know who it is right now
uh the lat now listen the last episode
we we went through basically your life
chronologically and your upbringing how
you ended up in the teams you know
growing up with your dad as a a war hero
himself a fighter pilot and what your
experience was like in the teams
and if people want to get that
background which you definitely do I I
actually re-listened to the podcast and
it's just it's awesome to listen to uh
it's episode 290. so if you want to hear
you know all the the backstory
from the Admiral's life growing up then
then go check out episode 290 but look
this is a new book though it's called
the wisdom of the bullfrog and there's
certainly a lot of wisdom in it and so
uh let's get into this thing
um
when this come out came out April 4th it
just came out a couple weeks ago yeah so
you say here in this
leadership is difficult but not
complicated
to do it right doesn't require a
sophisticated chart a calculus formula
or a complex algorithm but it does
require some guidance so how do we make
the difficult nature of leadership
simple well for thousands of years
militaries have relied on mottos Creeds
Parables and stories to inspire to
motivate and to guide leaders and
followers alike these sayings serve to
reinforce certain behaviors they provide
a memory prompt a pavlovian response and
an inspirational surge that helps direct
individual actions in the midst of
uncertainty
so that is the basis of This Book Is
that there's these military mantras that
you hear
and
you're definitely going to hear them and
depending on what unit you're in you may
hear certain ones more often than others
but what's you can you can definitely
take those things and kind of shrug them
off like no big deal but what you've
done in this book is pointed out how
they truly can be a mental checklist
about how you are going to function and
what decisions you're going to make and
I often say uh culture good culture is
the ultimate form of decentralized
command so if if and I actually talk
about the Marine Corps a lot because the
Marine Corps is such a strong culture
that every Marine understands what a
marine ultimately should be doing and
they know when they're doing right they
know what they're doing wrong and they
can make decisions based on just the
culture of the Marine Corps and a lot of
that culture comes from these mantras
that they have even right down to you
know semper Fidel is always faithful so
that's really the basis of this book and
and and you know taking these
mantras and mottos and breaking them
down and talking about how
you discovered them and then you let
them guide you yeah you know it's just a
couple of years ago my publisher got a
hold of me and said uh hey what would
you think about writing a leadership
book
and of course the other books as you
pointed out make a bad hero code they're
they're different styles they're not
really leadership books they are books
about you know various qualities and
traits and things that I think make for
you know good Heroes and but it's not a
leadership book and I said yeah I'd love
to write a leadership book but I
struggle with it because I had so much I
wanted to say about leadership that I
couldn't figure out how to frame the
book I actually had to push it off for a
year I wrote my uh got back hold of my
publisher and said I I can't do this
just right now I haven't figured it out
yet
well at one point in time I think was
after a couple of martinis or a couple
of beers I I started thinking Okay so
how did I learn leadership what were the
things that resonated with me and I
remembered very distinctly when I was a
young officer at one point in time I was
getting ready to do something and and
the guy that was kind of my mentor at
the time said to me hey if you do this
can you stand before the long green
table
and so that quote which has been around
for a while really kind of comes from
World War II and back in the day and
actually even when I joined the the
teams in the early 70s we still had them
the conference tables in the the
conference rooms long you know piece of
wooden table but it had a very thin
green felt that was on top of the
conference tables and so whenever there
was some sort of official proceeding or
something you as the officer who was
being questioned would come and stand
before the long green table and the
implication of that saying can you stand
before the long green table is look if
you're about to make a decision or
you're going to take an action if you
had to stand before reasonable men and
women who were judging those actions
could you do it and make a case for it
because if you can't then you better
rethink your actions and so again if for
some reason when I was an Ensign this
came up and ever since then
when I had a very difficult decision
when something seemed very risky or I
would say to myself okay
if this goes south which it very well
could
I justify why I took these actions and
then I and that was kind of the Epiphany
for me in terms of well shoot it's not
only the long green table of course it's
the seal Mantra the only easy day was
yesterday because we as seals of course
understand immediately that every day is
hard so then I started thinking well
what are the other quotes and mottos and
as you said mantras and that became the
framing mechanism for the book but the
first one that jumped out was this long
green table yeah that's a that's a good
one there's a modern version of that
that I used to tell guys and that is
you're out there in the field and you do
something you have to assume that it's
going to be on CNN right yeah it's the
Washington Post CNN test you're right
they're going to be sitting there
there's someone with a camera that
person that you think is just you know
running away they're actually filming
and so you got to think it was what I'm
is what I'm about to do
am I going to be proud of this if it
goes on you know viral over and everyone
watches it and that you know some people
might say well that's not that's not the
right attitude to have because that
means you were thinking about doing
something bad well if it's the thing
that keeps you in check and from doing
something bad then so be it right
uh and speaking of which this is the
first one that you go over in this is is
kind of the CL it might be the most
classic of these mantras it's death
before dishonor and honestly uh you sent
me a PDF of this and and I was reading
it and I said well that's he's coming
out of the gate with death before
dishonor okay and you say this in the
book Legend has it that the phrase death
before dishonor began with the Greek
stoics who were prepared to die rather
than compromise their values later
Julius Caesar is quoted as saying I love
the name of Honor more than I fear death
the samurai of Japan were steeped in the
tradition of honor and always prepared
to die rather than dishonor their
service to their emperor and in modern
times the United States Marine Corps has
unofficially adopted the saying death
before dishonor after Legendary Marine
Sergeant John Basilone
had the motto tattooed on his left arm
so that's like the hardcore take
um but what I think the the the slant
that you put on this or the the
perspective that you put on this
is applying this not to oh I'm facing
the enemy and I'd rather die than run
away but hey I've got a hard decision to
make and I'd rather do the right thing
The Honorable thing
then then and have to suffer a little
bit then take the easy way out yeah the
um and and I I struggled early on with
deciding whether or not that should be
chapter one and frankly even the term
death before dishonor I'm thinking okay
somebody's going to pick up this book
and go
you gotta be kidding me this is as you
said right out of the gate uh we're
gonna come on hard but I realized and
and you know this exceedingly well Jocko
at the end of the day
the great leaders the men and women that
we respect are those people that are
honorable that are honest that are
trustworthy that kind of respect the
people they work for now we all have our
foibles and I point out in the book
several times look
um I'm very cautious about you know
offering advice to people recognizing my
own shortfalls
but if you don't have a code of honor a
personal code of honor and pick
something and I I list a lot of them in
there it's not just you know death
before dishonor I mean the Boy Scout
code the Girl Scout code the Hippocratic
oath I mean there's a lot of things out
there that recognize the value of honor
the one I kind of pull out is uh is from
West Point when I went up there uh to do
what's called the 500th night I had an
opportunity to talk to the Juniors that
were going through West Point
and the the kind of honor code for West
Point is about as simple as it gets it
says I will not lie cheat
steal or tolerate those who do
and I thought that's it it doesn't have
to be death you know yeah it's not about
dying but it is about doing the right
thing and you always know you know
people have asked me before well you
don't always know what the right thing
to do oh hell yeah of course you know
the right thing to do it's just hard to
do and in fact the the beginning of the
book I start off with a quote from Carl
Von Klaus witz the 19th century
president General who wrote the the book
on War
and in the book on War which is why the
subtitle he says everything in war is
simple
it's just the simple things are
difficult and I remember
I was heading back to Afghanistan in
about 2009 I'm I'm on a plane and I'm
reading some foreign policy magazine and
and this is when we had just become kind
of the surge to Afghanistan
and these two kind of East Coast
academics are talking about the fact
that you know the military a little
condescending the military just doesn't
get it in Afghanistan if they would only
build roads they could connect the
villages to the districts and the
districts to the province and then you
know build more roads the province to
the central government the military just
doesn't get it you know why don't they
build roads well no why didn't we
think of that and the answer is we did
think of that it's just that when people
are shooting at you and trying to blow
you up it's a little hard to build roads
and so this was a little bit of the
foundation of my thinking on leadership
you say hey be an honorable man or woman
well that that sounds easy you know I
could get up on a chalkboard and say you
know lead from the front take care of
your men and women you know be men and
women of a good character it's just hard
to do it's hard to do because we're
humans we make mistakes we have our
foibles you know you say We'll lead from
the front except when people are
shooting at you sometimes
do you have the courage always to lead
from the front when all of a sudden you
realize your reputation or your
advancement or your promotion hinges on
something some action you're going to
take are you going to do the honorable
thing
but what I've found over time
and frankly the older and more
experienced I get the more I think this
is true is yes there are captains of
industry out there who have built you
know billion dollar Enterprises there
are you know companies there are
universities but invariably
if they have not been honorable
it's a house of cards they're building
it's the enrons of this world it's the
Layman Brothers of this world it's the
universities that are seeking a national
championship but have recruiting
violations pick something invariably
those organizations or those people will
have an existential event because they
were not honorable because they thought
the ends Justified the means
and so this idea of honor is not just
some kind of pollyanish view it's it's
really something that you find if you do
it and you do it well
and even when you go off track if you
know what's right you can kind of come
back and do the honorable thing again
and it'll make for a better organization
it'll make for a better culture uh it
will make for a better human being not
easy to do but you know what it looks
like
yeah I think another thing that I that I
think about as well similar to what
you're saying
is
usually the unhonorable thing the easy
road is going to be a short-term win
it's going to be a short-term
gratification but like you just said
ultimately strategically it's going to
be a loser so when you're taking that
when you when you cave to the pressure
when you make a decision that you know
is not the the best way to go about this
when you when you make those mistakes or
you make those decisions you're going to
find out in the long run that that was
not the right thing to do I had uh my
platoon Commander
and we were on an ARG platoon my platoon
Commander was CB
and so we oh by the way so I'm sorry to
interject here but you know CB and I
were sharing the bullfrog for the first
year yeah one of the finest officers I
ever served with as you know yeah so CB
he was my platoon Commander and we were
on an ARG platoon so we go in to do a
hydrographic reconnaissance there's big
waves it's up at Camp Pendleton it's
miserable it's freezing we're in the
boat I'm in the boat pool because I'm a
radio man we suffer through the night
the swimmers are getting washed up on
the beach it's just it's just a horrible
event it takes us all night to get it
done we get it done we're freezing cold
we get back to the ship the the
Cartographer from the platoon the two
guys they go and make the chart they
give it to the Marine Corps the we go
back in to the beach we call in the
Marines the Marine we're freezing we're
suffering it's just miserable we get
done
the Marines land and an hour after the
Marines land they turn around go back
they said they they go back out to the
ships we're going what's happening turns
out the Marines didn't like the way the
The Landing went down they say we didn't
do a good job we want to do the whole
thing again
so we get tasked once again but we're
gonna do repeat of the operation so
we're doing another hydrographic
reconnaissance we all Pile in the zodiac
boats we do the 12 nautical miles over
the beach due to to get to the beach we
put this where we're sitting there in
this boat pool
and we just did we just did this
hydrographic reconnaissance not well I
guess it was 36 hours before
and it's hard work you know this is like
six or seven hours of swimming yeah
so we're sitting in this boat pool
and and
there's kind of a silence
and finally someone thank God it wasn't
me says you know uh hey are we actually
gonna do this again
and there's silence and then CB says
well we don't have to
but would that be the right thing to do
and as soon as we heard that everyone
was just like oh whoever said that it's
a terrible person we all were so glad we
didn't say ourselves but you were all
thinking it right so that for me that
was the quote that you heard of the long
green table that for me that was my
second platoon and that for me is this
the right thing to do and there's an
easy way to do it and I actually we just
did the hydrographical process it was
totally good to go we could have easily
sat in those boats and relaxed for a
little while
but it wouldn't have been the right
thing to do and that guidance from from
CB stuck with me for for the rest of my
career into this day uh that's where
those things come from but that's one of
those situations where look he's feeling
the pressure from from the platoon
that's going to be suffering for the
next five hours six hours seven hours
but he knew it wasn't the right thing to
do it and but the interesting thing was
all he had to do is ask the question
would that be the right thing to do
and we all knew that wasn't the right
thing so that's why Brian siebenaller
was one of the great officers in the
Seal team oh absolutely I've I tried to
steal as much leadership as I possibly
could from him and
he was the guy that made me realize well
first of all he's the guy that made me
want to become an officer because I said
to myself we had we had fired up a
platoon commander and he took over and
and when he took over I was like gosh
this is awesome like this is so it's a
totally different world right and I said
if one day maybe I can make the world
good for 16 guys in a seal platoon
that's what I'm going to do I think you
did that I think you did that Jocko for
more than more than a few guys sent me
down the path but all thanks to CB all
thanks to him and and just the example
that he set as a as a as a leader and as
a frog man he was also just awesome at
everything you know he was just awesome
at PT and we of course of course thought
he was an old man because he was because
he had gray hair you must have been at
least well he had been a Senior Chief I
think before in his senior year before
he became an o yeah so
um so there you go that that attitude
right there
you say you rap you I'm not going to do
this for every chapter but you you have
a little wrap up in these chapters you
say it's simple
to be be fair and honorable in your
business dealings it's the only way that
you and your employees can leave a
legacy to be proud of never lie cheat
steal or tolerate those who do the
culture of your organization starts with
you own your lapses in judgment it
happens to everyone correct the problem
and return to being a person of good
character
how does that mesh up with uh if you
ain't cheating you ain't trying
yeah you know I never liked that saying
so uh Jocko's referring to us saying
when we go through SEAL training a lot
of times I say if you ain't cheating you
ain't trying
um and I and it concerns me that this
continues to be kind of discussed and
bought into in the training to me it was
about are you being
um
are you being flexible enough are you
being creative enough it wasn't about
cheating it was about being creative it
was about having this kind of Commando
mentality that says okay you want me to
go from point A to point B but I
understand the best way to do this isn't
to go from point A to point B to go from
point A to point a and a half and do it
faster than you would think you know and
and you would find creative ways to
solve problems
sometimes people said well the
instructor said to do it this way so if
you're not doing it that way then you're
obviously cheating
and you know that's as you know as a
former instructor that's not exactly
what you were trying to do you were
trying to find out who were the leaders
in the class that could think on their
feet that could be creative when they
were when they were given a challenging
problem
but from the student standpoint they're
like well I'm sorry the instructor said
it's through this exactly and now you're
telling me to do something different you
the O in the class
it's not cheating it is about you know
thinking differently and thinking
creatively and and uh you know this is
what's expected of of all leaders
particularly those of us in the in the
kind of the Commando broad Commando
ranks
um so yeah the cheating piece I never
liked that saying don't like it today
because I think it implies that uh you
are circumventing
the
um you know the ground truth of
something you're trying to do something
illegal or wrong in terms of cheating
you're violating the rules now you're
not violating the rules you're playing
within the rules you're just being
creative in how you do it and it sounds
nuanced but I do think it's a it's a
different approach to things yeah that
when I went through we we'd heard it we
said it and then eventually the
instructors
would say you're only cheating
yourselves right which which made sense
to me but I I totally agree with what
you're saying I was going through
Mount Warfare like so Urban combat
training and I was assistant platoon
commander and I was out at Team two and
the the uh role players you know the
other seals that are acting like bad
guys they captured one of our guys
and they had him in like the third third
story of this building
and they were you know was getting all
theatrical they had him yelling for help
and all this stuff and we're all you
know like oh we gotta get him
and we had been taught hey you know when
you enter a building you clear you clear
the first floor then you move to the
second floor you clear the second floor
then you get to the third floor you go
to the third floor
and to me it was like oh they were going
to wait and they were to cause problems
for us and they were going to kill this
guy and so I said hey here's what we're
gonna do I said we're just going
straight to the third floor we're gonna
get on this outside stairwell we're
gonna go right to the third floor and
don't clear any of the other rooms
because we could tell what what Romeo
was in I was going straight up there I'm
gonna write to that room and sure enough
I mean this was within two minutes you
know they expected us to come up with a
plan and then reassess and then go clear
the building from the top to bottom so
within two minutes we're in that on that
ladder well heading up and sure enough
we we literally walked into that room
and just shot all the bad guys in the
back and and surprised them to me that's
what that motto is about it's about
thinking about outside the box
absolutely right being creative thinking
outside the box getting the problem
solved uh without necessarily following
through the all the steps that you think
are necessary I mean that that's what's
expected of good officers good leaders
uh next one you can't surge Trust
and in this one
um and again yeah I'm obviously skipping
around this book get the book there's
all every every one of these you give
really good one two maybe three examples
of where these things played in history
where they played in your career
they're just it's just a great
compilation of these things the the Crux
of this one to be a great leader you
must be trusted by your employees if
they do not trust you they will not
follow you it takes time to build trust
but it is time well spent if you intend
to lead effectively now you say
employees in this yeah it's actually not
just your employees it's your peers and
it's the people above you in the chain
of command and you go into that and
that's one of the major uh points of the
entire book
this idea of building relationships
and you talk about building trust and
and I've been talking a lot lately about
what relationships are what what are
they and I talk about well trust is
definitely one of them if you don't
trust me and I don't trust you we don't
have a relationship listening if I don't
listen to you and you don't listen to me
we don't have relationship respect if I
don't treat you with respect and you
don't treat me with respect and it
doesn't matter if if you're the Admiral
and I'm the chief
I'm going to treat you with respect and
you're going to treat me with respect
and if we're not treating each other
respect we don't have a good
relationship and by the way if you're
the Admiral and I'm a chief and you
don't cheat me with respect we don't
have a good relationship absolutely
you're not going to get much from me
beyond what you mandate
uh being able to influence so if you
gotta you gotta actually open your mind
and allow other people to influence you
so that you can have influence with them
if I don't listen to anything you say or
I don't allow you to influence my ideas
we're not going to move forward and the
last one obviously is take care
if you don't care about me I don't care
about you we don't have a relationship
um
this idea of trust and this is a
question I've gotten asked many many
times is you know my boss is telling me
to do something that doesn't make sense
what do I tell the troops I've already
told my boss it doesn't make sense but
he's just saying go ahead and do it
anyways
and I always tell people yeah when that
would happen to me and believe me it
happened to me just like I know what
happened to you it's gonna happen with
no matter what career you're in I would
get told to do something that didn't
make sense what did I do did I go back
to my troops and say hey this doesn't
make any sense the boss is stupid
because that's the truth no what I'd say
is Hey listen here's what the boss wants
us to do I'm not exactly sure why he
wants to stick with his plan but I do
know this I want the boss to trust me
and what we're going to do is we're
going to do this we're going to do the
best of our ability we're going to knock
it out of the park so that the boss
realizes that we're a good platoon and
we can get the job done and he trusts me
and that way the next time he's got a
wild idea like this he'll hopefully
listen to me a little bit more
so being able to tell the truth is so
important and there's really no reason
to deviate from that
yeah you know certainly in my time in
Iraq and Afghanistan uh you know there
were times where we were looking at
doing pretty complex missions and
sometimes a lot of times you know you're
putting the troops at high risk and I
always felt that as the commander I had
an obligation and you talk about the
trust I had an obligation to sit down
with
the platoon the unit that whatever
happened to be and say guys here's why
we're doing this and you've got to be
prepared to hear their concerns I mean
to your point you got to listen you've
got to listen to their concerns but what
you hope is that the good leaders and I
talk about sergeant major Chris Ferris
in here a lot so the sergeant major as
you know was my command sergeant major
both at jsoc and then at Socom
and Ferris never hesitated never
hesitated to come into my office close
the door and say Hey sir this is a bad
idea or have you thought about it this
way and you need someone like that that
is that is going to tell truth to power
and you expect certainly as a leader I
always expected and I encouraged the you
know the officers at work for me the
senior Enlisted the work for me to say
hey look boss you know I need to tell
you something good tell me you know I
won't wire brush you for it I need to
know what your concerns are or I'm going
to make a bad decision
and uh and Ferris would always come in
and and we'd have the conversation but
once I made the decision and this is an
important part of leadership is the
followership part of it once I made the
decision even if Ferris disagreed with
it or even if the master Chiefs that
worked for me before disagreed with it
they would say okay sir I got it they'd
kind of salute smartly and move out and
they owned that decision in fact I
talked about this discussion at uh at
West Point so I have all these you know
a thousand kids or whatever there were
Juniors at West Point Cadets
and I said you need to be very careful
about kind of becoming as a junior
officer because I know I fell into this
trap when I was a young Junior officer
the commanding officers of you know my
teams they were old guys you know they
were probably in their 40s or something
uh and you know they were balding and
maybe they'd put on a little weight and
you know as a junior officer you tend to
kind of make a little fun of them and
you know that their spouses weren't
exactly you know and you get a little
too righteous you know I mean you're
like oh you know this guy just doesn't
understand how things are done you know
and I told these young Cadets I said be
careful about being too righteous and
thinking that you know more than the
commanding officer or the person senior
to you because when you get to be that
person and if you're lucky enough to be
that person one day you will find all of
the the things that are uh that are
impressing upon that individual to have
them be forced to make certain decisions
why they're doing things certain ways
and uh and really you know you have an
obligation as a leader to explain the
decisions you're making people say well
as a leader you don't have to explain
anything oh yeah you do of course you do
particularly When people's lives are at
risk you have to explain why you're
doing it but you hope that once you've
explained it and once people have talked
it out when the decision is made the
good kind of follower leaders they say
okay boss I own that decision just like
you were talking about hey if the manual
officer wants us done we're going to do
it to the very best of our ability
um and you know that that served me well
both as a senior leader and as a
follower later mm-hmm
I have good conversations with people
and along these lines
and they'll say yeah but you know what
if I go in to explain the why we're
doing something and I start getting
asked asked questions
and I don't know what the answer is and
I always say well maybe your idea is not
that great maybe you need to rethink
what your actual plan is if I can't
articulate to you hey this is why we're
attacking this target from the North or
this is why we're moving on to this
target from the south this is what this
is why we're using helicopters if I
can't articulate that to you in a way
where you nod your head and go yeah okay
I understand that makes sense well maybe
I should actually listen to a little bit
more to what you have to seven I've been
using this uh my my latest patented
Adventure invention is called the
explanation effort meter okay and what
this is is
how hard is it for me to make it to
explain why we're doing something and at
a certain point if I'm exerting so much
effort to try and explain something that
if that means if that meter starts
getting in the red I might need to
rethink what my decision is well
actually when I became the chancellor of
the University of Texas system uh my
first day on the job so now all of a
sudden I'm in charge of 230 000 kids 100
000 employees 14 different institutions
I've got no experience in higher
education or health care and and and
this was you know the huge part of the
University system
so I come in to meet my staff and I had
met them a little bit ahead of time but
this is really my first meeting
and as I had done frankly at socomet
jsocket every command I'd ever been at I
sit down with him and I said okay folks
let me tell you how this works I said
you know they're going to be times when
I'm making decisions
and if I'm making the wrong decision
please tell me give me your input I want
your input and I want you to feel free
and comfortable to talk to me if things
don't seem right
but here's the other part of this
if I find out later on that you knew I
was walking into a Minefield and you
didn't tell me you and I are going to
have a conversation and so it was one
you've got as a leader you've got to
create an environment where whether it's
your staff or the platoon or whoever is
comfortable talking to you and saying
hey this is all screwed up
um but at the same time they also need
to know that there's a little bit of
pressure that if they see you doing
something wrong and they don't tell you
guess what that was their responsibility
too uh and again that served me well
over time both in the military and out
and out of the military yeah yeah the
the other thing that comes to play is do
you really think you know when the boss
tells me to do something that doesn't
seem to make much sense is that because
the boss wants us to lose a bunch of
money or you know not be able to take
care of a client or make a bad product
or in combat does that mean oh the boss
just wants us all to get killed that's
why no that's not happening they just
don't see something that you see or or
you haven't done a good job
communicating up the chain of command so
that you can explain hey boss actually
here's a new TTP that Danny's been using
this is not a good idea oh well thank
you for telling me that
so uh all good stuff uh next one when in
command command and this is like I said
you've got a bunch of uh stories in here
some of them history some from your
experience this one here is from it's
actually you going to college and you're
learning about
um
learning about Admiral Nimitz
and you hear this in the spring of 1942
the Intelligence on the Japanese
intentions at Midway was anything but
solid
many in the Admiral's own ranks question
the Strategic Benefit of trying to save
Midway and even more officers feared
that an American defeat at Midway would
mean a quick Japanese victory in the
Pacific the ramifications of a bad
decision were calamitous but the
ramification of no decision might be an
existential disaster Nimitz reviewed the
intelligence consulted with his staff
and talked with his commanders but the
ultimate decision was his he anguished
over the decision for days what would
happen if he were wrong thousands of
sailors might die thousands more would
perish in fighting on Midway and the
island chains leading to Japan the fate
of the entire Navy and perhaps our
nation rested on this decision
Legend has it that during a conversation
with Admiral Bull Halsey Nimitz
confessed his apprehension the weight of
the decision about Midway was
overwhelming him Halsey blunt as ever
reminded the Admiral of nimitz's own
personal conviction you once told me
Halsey began that when in command
command
it was the Clarion call that Nimitz
needed he understood that commanders are
expected to make the tough decision to
act with purpose to be confident and
lead from the front to accept the
challenge and steal yourself for the
Rough Waters ahead a commander must
command command the situation command
the troops command your fears take
command
um
and like I said this was a this was a a
course that you got when you were an uh
I think a midshipman or midship ROTC and
what what I really found uh just pretty
amazing was I'm going to read a little
bit more of the book here it says 38
years later as a four-star Admiral and
commander of the U.S Special Operations
Command I walked into my office in Tampa
to find a new desk waiting for me I was
a bit confused as the old desk had
seemed perfectly fine
when I inquired about the desk my
administrative assistant senior master
sergeant Dana Hughes smiled and said
well sir we thought this might be a
better fit for you perplexed I looked at
the desk again it was older than I first
realized a large executive style desk
with deep grain wood and leather side
panels as I approached the desk there
was a small framed picture resting on
the edge
the man in the picture was unmistakable
it was Admiral Chester Nimitz and this
was his desk the Navy archives had been
kind enough to loan it to Socom for my
use
I was humbled beyond all measure for the
next three years I sat at that desk and
whenever I thought I had some difficult
days I would remember where I was
sitting I would remember the lives that
hung in the balance the decisions that
affected Millions the sense of loss and
the sense of victory that Nimitz must
have felt and on those days when I felt
indecisive when I took too much counsel
of my fears
when worry threatened to stall my
actions I hearkened back to nimitz's
words when in command command
and with those words is my guide I
always tried to do the right do right by
the men and women who served me
man
sometimes people really do the right
thing don't they whoever figured hey we
got the four star admiral that's now
running
all the Special Operations we need to
get him nimitz's desk that's incredible
so Dana Hughes was this remarkable
senior master sergeant as I mentioned
the Air Force senior Mass Sergeant
reward for me out in my front office and
uh yeah at one point in time I think I
had flippantly said something about you
know I need something navel around here
you know because as you know so I'm not
Eric Olsen had been right before me but
historically Socom had been an army
command and and frankly still was
adorned with a lot of army uh you know
memorabilia so I'd gone away on a on a
trip for a couple of weeks uh if I was
heading over to Afghanistan or something
and I come back and and here's this desk
and of course nobody says anything when
I come in but I see a little grin on
Dana's you know face as a as I come back
out and say
what is this desk
and she said very you know
straightforces well you said you wanted
something Naval
she says it's nimitz's desk and I was
like you're kidding and as you point out
it really was for me it was kind of a
physical manifestation
of the difficulty of command
but of course my decisions as the
commander of Socom pailed in comparison
to any decisions that Chester Nimitz had
to make and so you know you realize look
you have an obligation as a commander as
any leader I don't care whether you're
leading Starbucks or whether you're
leading you know a hamburger joint
people expect you as the leader to make
the decisions to make the hard decisions
and yeah it's hard good luck you're in
command you know you're in charge make
the hard decisions and there were times
you know as the socom commander and as
the Json Commander you you struggle with
these things but when you realize that
people have come before you that have
had to make really really you know
Monumental decisions and they did the
right thing then you need to do what is
right by the people that work for you
you need to make the decision you're
going to be wrong A lot of times I was
wrong A lot of times
but frankly they appreciate the
decisiveness of the people in leadership
positions now again this also assumes
that you've taken all the advice and as
I I talk about the little story about
Nimitz at a time his staff had had told
him so we think this is a bad idea you
know sailing the fleet out to Midway
this could be a Japanese trap
the folks in in DC the senior officers
in DC did not think it was a good idea
but nimitz's experience at that point in
time you know he'd been in the in the
Navy for 30 plus years at that point in
time he really had an understanding of
what the right thing to do was he just
he struggled with making that decision
of course as you know Jocko bull hauls
the admirable Halsey was this kind of
bigger than life figure in the Navy
Brash uh very uh you know courageous and
and uh risk not risk adverse
um and he had this kind of gruff
demeanor and so when uh when Nimitz
comes in he goes well Admiral you always
told me you know winning command command
and uh and so that that has stuck with
me all these years that uh from my time
as a midshipmen again getting this this
course in in the ROTC yeah yeah you got
to make tough decisions when you're in
command that's what's expected of you
yeah and you mentioned the fact that you
look this is after you've listened to
people and and you gotta in your in your
uh breakout here you say
be decisive don't take too much counsel
of your fears be thoughtful but not
paralyzed by indecision now this is a
much well not much but this is a
slightly different version
of patents what you know what patent
gets attributed to quote of uh do not
take counsel of your fears period do not
take counsel of your fears what you say
is don't take too much counsel of your
fears
this is why I wrote a book called The
dichotomy of leadership because if
you're not balanced and if if someone
reads this if you're a young Junior
officer right now in the military and
you say hey when it's time to command
command I'm gonna just make decisions
that's not what we're that's not what
I'm gonna say that's right it's actually
listen make sure you assess and then
when you when it's time to make a
decision you make a decision
don't take too much counsel of your
fears that means you should actually
listen to your fears you if you if
something is if you're saying I don't
know if this is the right thing to do
okay what is explore that right don't
just say oh I'm a commander so I'm just
going to command
um well let me uh dovetail off that
because later on the book I talk about
who dares wins and as you know the the
Special Air Service British Special Air
Service that's their motto who dares
wins
but I'm quick to point out in the who
dares wins piece of this is yes you want
to be aggressive yes you want to take
risk but they need to be calculated
risks and and so I also want to make
sure that the reader understands and and
part of this course is talking a little
bit about the bin Laden raid and I said
look everybody and I'm not sure I talked
about in the book but everybody that's
seen the movie Zero Dark Thirty which I
have not seen by the way uh long story
behind why I haven't seen it but I have
not seen the movie that makes two of us
either so so
um but but I know in movies about seals
you know what they show of course is you
know the Darian Dew and the sexy stuff
that makes movies or books what they
don't talk about is that three quarters
of your time is spent planning and
rehearsing right uh you know nobody
wants to see a bunch of seals on a
whiteboard with gutter markers but as
you well know you don't do that up front
work then the mission goes awry so this
understanding of yes who dares wins or
winning command command to your point
Jaco you bet you know you want to be
decisive but you want to be decisive
after you have thought through all the
risks after you have taken all as much
of the risk out of it as you possibly
can then be prepared to move out listen
to the people that are providing you
that counsel uh listen to your fears I
mean you have reasonably uh you know
counsel of your fears you ought to
listen to that little voice in the back
of your head that says I don't know here
sooner or later though you've got to say
you've got to resolve that okay if the
little voice in the back of my head says
hey you know you guys are jumping out
too high or you're jumping out too low
or you're going into a risky situation
to get the shadow governor of this
province and do you really want to you
ought to think through that
but then once you've thought through it
you can't be paralyzed by your decision
you know it's uh you know you can't have
this analysis by paralysis and continue
and continue and continue sooner or
later you've got to make the decision to
move out
here's a little trick I used to play on
the junior officers
um when when they were coming through
the Yahtzee course the junior officer
training course so I was over running
trade at my buddy Leif was running the
junior officer training course and I
would set the scenario up for him it was
a scenario that we lived through which
was we were we were
got a got a mission in ramadi for a
hostage rescue we get the word that this
guy had been kidnapped somewhere in
Fallujah and now we have the location he
had been moved by these insurgents to
ramadi and he was being held hostage and
they wanted fifty thousand dollars money
that was going to finance the Insurgency
we the first thing we got when we got
this word I said let's just wait let's
get this confirmed this sounds it
sounded a little bit wild so sure enough
we wait 24 hours we gather more
intelligence and it gets more solid more
solid more solid and we've got grit now
we have really good Intel you know the
probably the best Intel that you can get
we have that this guy where he is and
what's going on so okay we're gonna go
rescue this guy we
you know the platoon does their platoon
planning they're they're briefing the
mission
I'm sitting there and and there's a
bunch of things that happen on this that
made it a very interesting mission
so we come up with a plan we're gonna go
hit this Target and
we get done with the brief
and the Ensign I had the Intel you know
I was at a I was a task unit of 40 seals
you know we our Intel officer was an
instant a great guy but he comes running
in and and sir sir and I'm like what's
going on he goes Ouija I just got more
Intel and I'm like okay what is it and
the blaze standing there with me and he
says
we just got until that
they have IEDs planted throughout the
yard and they have heavy machine guns
and if anybody comes to try and rescue
this guy they're going to kill everyone
and they're going to kill him
and at that point so I would tell this
story to these Junior officer training
kids
and I'd say all right who would go on
this mission right now and half of them
would raise their hand and say yep we're
going we're going to rescue this guy
that's what we do
the other half would raise their hand
and say oh well I wouldn't send my guys
you know we're not gonna go take a bunch
of risks to get blown up by IEDs to to
rescue some random Iraqi kid
and so we we'd always get that you
always get and both those answers you
know you can see where they're both
coming from and my point into in setting
them up like this is I'd say hey that's
great that you guys think this that's
great that you other guys think this
here's the reality this isn't a black
and white question what we can actually
do is we can mitigate risk and that's
what exactly what we did you know so
what we did was we put an OverWatch on
the building we observed the fact that
there was people walking around we that
mitigated the fact that there was IEDs
we couldn't see any we would put air
assets overhead we realized there wasn't
any machine gun on the net on the on the
roof of the building
and then we did a massive explosive
breach on the gate which we normally
wouldn't do normally we'd climb into a
building but we did a massive explosive
breach which would disrupt IEDs we sent
dogs in first then Iraqis uh our Iraqi
counterparts we sent them in and then we
went in so my point was hey guys look
this is not always like a yes or no
answer a lot of times you just need to
rethink things and how can you mitigate
this to the best your ability and and
all that being said we would also add on
the point that
you can never mitigate all risk you
can't mitigate all risk and what you do
is you mitigate what you can and
regardless if we were going on that
Target or some other Target we would
make adjustments based on the Threat
Level and so
yes when you're in command command
but think right
it seems intuitive but it isn't always
you're right yeah it and you know the
really scary thing is when people let
their ego get wrapped around issues like
that and I've been pointing out to
people lately that there's countless you
wouldn't think that your ego would get
you killed or you wouldn't think that
you wouldn't make an egotistical
decision that would get thousands of men
killed but there's just example upon
historical example of combat where
people let their ego just drive people
to their own death and sometimes
including themselves
all right speaking of ego
um you gotta the next one is we all have
our frog floats which actually told the
story on the on the first time you came
on the podcast but it's worth rehashing
you got your you first show up at a Seal
Team or as actually a UDT team and of
course you expect the big mission is
coming
and you get recalled and by the way you
get recalled by a guy named uh uh Petty
Officer Larry L Jones comes and tells
you hey they need to see you right now
the skipper needs to see you
and interestingly
with one of these crossover things this
guy's a guy that was known in the SEAL
Teams is double level and when I was
when I got to Seal Team One there was a
Seal Team One ball
at the Hotel Del Coronado and we had a
cake and the cake Cutters were the
oldest seal at Seal Team One and the
youngest seal at Seal Team One and
Double L was the oldest seal at Seal
Team won and the youngest was me and so
yeah so there you go so you get recalled
for this big mission and the big mission
that you get recalled for is to uh
build a uh a parade float of a big frog
for the Fourth of July that's what you
get tasked with and obviously it wasn't
going into you know Soviet Harbors or
something like that so you're kind of
bummed out
now let's go to the book you see this
this uh you hear this this deep raspy
voice behind you in the locker room as
you're walking around all bummed out he
says what's the matter ensign
I turned around to see Master Chief
Herschel Davis the senior enlisted man
from our sister team UDT 12 Davis was
the personification of a frog Man Tall
lean tan with a ruddy face steel gray
eyes and a huge handlebar mustache he
had seen more combat action than any 10
men I knew nothing important Master
Chief uh-huh he said in a fatherly tone
as he took a seat beside me why did this
feel like I was in the confessional I
confessed Skipper just called me into
his office and told me he wants me to
take charge of building
the Frog float for the Fourth of July
parade
the Master Chief grunted and my guess is
you would rather be jumping out of
airplanes locking out of submarines
going on a mission to save the world
exactly right
I told him let me tell you something
Henson I've been in this Canoe Club for
almost 30 years sooner or later we all
have to do things we don't want to do
but if you're going to do it then do it
right build the best damn frog float you
can
and there it was build the best damn
frog float you can
throughout the rest of my career I would
be asked to build a lot of frog floats
asked to do those menial tasks that no
one else wanted those tasks that seemed
beneath the Dignity of my rank but each
time I remembered the words of the
Master Chief and tried to do the best I
could to be proud of whatever job I was
given I found in my career that if you
took pride in the little jobs people
would think you were the of the bigger
jobs on July 4th 1978 the UDT frog float
was awarded the top prize in its
category and the picture of my first
mission hung proudly in the UDT 11
compound for years afterwards
it was funny so as I was promoting this
book I think it was Fareed Zakaria it
was my first TV spot a couple of weeks
ago and Farid had read the book and the
uh and and I think people wondered not
necessarily free but people wondered
okay was it is this just some story or
was it really a frog float and of course
I had a picture of the fraud float so I
I sent it after the fact I sent it to
Fareed and he was like whoa that's a big
float I said yes it was a so you may
recall because I think it went out to
the island the Frog eventually went out
the island so later on so it was this
giant paper mache frog that we had built
around a four by truck
and and then we pulled a flatbed and on
the flatbed we had the capsule from one
of the uh uh the Apollo missions I think
and then we built some you know fake
wave and then we had a bunch of guys on
an IBS I mean it was quite quite to do
but but after that that was the last
time that frog float was used well
eventually they took the paper mache
frog off of the the chassis of this
truck and they sent it out to San
Clemente Island and they put it on the
top of the hill where when I went
through training in class 95 we used to
do what they called airplanes you'd take
a pow wooden pallet put it on your back
and run up the hill we did it too so
later on when the Frog finally got out
there the guys had to carry frog eggs
you know which were big bull to find the
big boulder and carry it up the hill to
the Frog you know to the mother frog but
eventually a storm came in wiped out the
Frog and it was never seen again uh but
you know the point of that chapters you
all know is look you know all of us uh
you know and it goes back a little bit
what you said earlier about kind of
leadership and and when your boss says
asked you to do something you don't
always know the reason uh and the point
I'm making there is look if if at the
end of the day it's best for the
organization and look my commanding
officer thought building the Frog float
was good for UDT 11 and good for the the
teams and it was going to represent us
in the city of Coronado that was you
know his idea and the commodore's idea
well I mean if that's what they want
done and uh and I've been tasked to do
it then just do the best damn job you
can and throughout the course of my
career I said you you got tasks do a lot
of things I remember as a seal one time
on deployment Adam Marine Colonel come
to me and he says look you know you guys
you got this this Cracker Jack seal
platoon here Elite Commandos I need you
to clean up the beach
and we were in Colombia and the beach
had been you know polluted it had you
know trash all over the place I'm like
really
I mean we're like a world-class steel
platoon and you want us to skin dive and
pick up trash on the beach
and uh and McConnell said yeah we need
you to do this great for community
relations and so I had to back here if I
had to go back to talk to the platoon
and needless to say my seal platoon was
not too happy that we were gonna go
clean up the beach
but an interesting thing happened we got
out there and of course I said sure if
that that's what you need us to do we'll
we'll clean up the beach you know and I
had to explain it to the platoon I'm not
sure I ever explained it quite well
enough but we got out there we cleaned
up the beach and of course afterwards
the locals come out and they brought us
beer and we had a little picnic
afterwards and it turned out to be a
great community service project guys had
a good time and actually we felt pretty
good about cleaning out the beach I mean
we picked up a lot of trash
and you had a lot of those then you know
you get into combat in Iraq and
Afghanistan you think there's no small
things to do but there's a lot of small
things people ask you to do things that
you think well you know I'm supposed to
be out here saving the world winning the
war in Iraq winning the war in
Afghanistan no we need you to do this
thing that seems insignificant but may
actually have a much better bigger role
to play you just do the best you can
yeah I know uh I was also tasked for the
Fourth of July
I wasn't an officer I was just an e dog
so I had to put on a prc77 and we got
put a bunch of camouflage paint on and
drove you know at high speed toward the
Boy Scout landing and then got out and
patrolled through the crowd
uh what year was that Jaco because I was
probably in charge of that Fourth of
July demonstration 19
it would have been 1992. so I got this
1991.
and yeah because you were the EXO there
and run
89.90 yeah yeah so I I addressed you
yeah because we're you know back then
which is a shame because a lot of people
said that I was actually outstanding in
the Fourth of July
but as you remember before 9 11 uh for
your audience listeners I mean Fourth of
July the seals every fourth July we'd
put on a big demonstration Gloria Bay
and it wasn't because later on when I
became the serial Seal Team three and
then the Commodore uh I ended up doing
it five times being in charge of it five
times I kept trying to get out of it
said this isn't fair I mean I've been
doing because it was like running a
complex tactical Mission did you know we
had free fallers we had static liners we
had sdv guys we had guys on you know the
the fast attack vehicles and and if you
screwed this up you know 40 000 people
were going to be watching seal screw up
and uh and and some of it was pretty
dangerous trying to jump into Glorietta
Bay and all this so it was my first
opportunity to run a complex seal
mission in front of a lot of people uh
and I remember Admiral Ray Smith who was
the Commodore one important time or it
was the Admiral uh we had done a
demonstration and and a Conex box I had
on a platform out in the middle of
Glorietta Bay caught fire and there was
this huge black billowy smoke that just
went from Coronado all the way over to
San Diego and needless to say that did
not go so well the Admiral Knight had a
conversation bill you know this is not
supposed to be sure I got it but we're
gonna fix those things were uh it was
even so I did it in 1992 and it was like
the massive crowd I mean when I got out
of that little Zodiac boat and started
patrolling like there was a crowd
pressed up against the shore it was
very popular Evolution but yeah since I
don't know we stopped there once
September 11th happened uh next one
the only easy day was yesterday uh and
this is something you know that
obviously is it comes from buds I think
it comes from buds or originally it
comes from buds but um
you say this here in 2002 when I was
serving in the bush White House the
commander of the East Coast seal seals
invited me down for a conference as was
typical of the seal Gathering we started
each day with an hour of calisthenics
followed by a long run and again listen
to podcast 290 you talk about this
parachute accident that you had a
terrible parachute accident you were all
messed up from that you weren't really
healed yet but here's this you know
here's this PT and so what are you going
to do you're going to man up and and go
do the PT so you get done with the PT
and now it's time for a run and you say
this as my fellow seals started off in a
Sprint I was only able to keep up for
the first hundred yards and then began
to fall back within a few minutes I
couldn't even see the pack anymore the
course was five laps around a two-mile
stretch of State Park as the minutes
passed and I lumbered along the first
runner a young seal Lieutenant began to
lap me slowing momentarily he pulled up
beside me and knowing about my parachute
accident gave me you're penetrating and
Confused look sir what the hell are you
doing he asked what do you mean I
responded he shook his head and said sir
why are you even out here you don't have
anything left to prove
before I could answer he bolted away and
ran off into the distance
I was a Navy SEAL captain at the time I
had already completed my major command
an important milestone in an officer's
career and to this young Lieutenant I
had nothing left to prove but I wanted
to tell him what I wanted to yell at the
top of my voice was how very wrong he
was the day you no longer believe you
have something to prove the day you no
longer believe you must give it your all
the day you think you are entitled to
special treatment the day you think all
your hard days are behind you is the day
you are no longer the Right leader for
the job
yeah I mean and you know this better
than most Jaco the fact the matter is
and I tell folks look you got to bring
it every day every
single day and sometimes you know as you
become more and more senior you think
well I got here maybe there's some perks
no the only perk you have
is working hard working harder than
everybody else he's got people watching
you more people watching you uh you know
the uh you should be honored to lead and
again whether you're leading a coffee
shop or a burger joint or whether you're
leading you know all U.S Special
Operations
you should recognize that
it's an honor to lead
there are no special perks come in
earlier than everybody else work harder
than everybody else stay late come in on
the weekends do whatever it takes to
take care of the men and women that are
working for you to get the job done
the only easy day really was yesterday
every day is going to be hard and the
day you start thinking that hey man my
easy days are behind me you know I've
made it you know I got money in my
pocket I'm a four-star Admiral I mean
things are good I really don't have to
work too much harder no that's not the
way it works you just got to work harder
this this led me or maybe think about
something again going back to this
junior officer training course that I
used to go in and guest lecture at if it
can be called that when when life was
running I did it when the other other
guys were running as well but one thing
I would tell those guys is you have
nothing to prove but everything to prove
and the reason I would tell them that is
because you get these young officers
sometimes and they would feel like they
had to prove that they were in charge so
they would dictate everything and they
would impose their will on the team and
they would make these decisions that
didn't really matter I mean like really
does it matter what you know I want to
meet at seven o'clock in the morning and
the chief says you know we're going to
meet at 7 15. you're no make it seven
like there's no there's really you just
lost so much leadership Capital trying
to prove that you were in charge so you
have nothing to prove but the
interesting dichotomy is you have
everything to prove you have to prove
that you're going to do the right things
at the right time make the right
decision that you're going to take care
of the team you're going to get the
mission accomplished that's what you're
trying to prove
so and that that's the external what
you're trying to prove and then you've
got here you know what you're talking
about this internal thing of like hey
every single day every day and they got
it they did a good job with the uh seal
ethos of uh you got to earn your Trident
every day
um that's uh
that doesn't go away well because you
know you're trying every day because you
owe it to all the people that came
before that wore the trident
and all the people that are gonna come
after you and you know and I always tell
people it ain't your Trident
yeah I got it you know it's on your
chest it's got your name but it's not
really your Triton it's everybody that
ever wore a trident it's it's the team's
reputation and so you better wear that
trident and remember the people that
came before you remember the people that
you're going to represent in the future
do it with honor do it with Integrity do
with all the right intentions because at
the end of the day
you know it's all of our tridents you're
just lucky enough to be wearing it
that's uh that's the truth right there
next one
run to the sound of the guns and you've
got a whole section in here about
one of my favorite leaders of all time
Joshua Lawrence Chamberlain we go we go
out to Gettysburg and we take people out
there and we do a battlefield you know
review
just it's just awesome you can actually
right now right now at this moment
little Roundtop is closed because it's
they're they're doing a bunch of work up
there but usually we get to go right up
on little round top right now we take
people up to Devil's Den and you can
look across that little round top but
we've done a bunch and we've I've on
this podcast we've covered the book
bayonet forward we've gone through that
thing in great detail well I also did
six podcasts taking us up to the Battle
of Gettysburg with a friend of mine
named JD who's a marine retired Marine
that worked at the Naval Academy who's
uh fanatic Civil War history buff uh so
yeah this is this talks about that event
happening and and what happened at the
Battle of Little Roundtop again you do a
great job of of capturing the essence of
that
um
and and you take this run to the sound
of the guns and break it down in your in
your
kind of capture here you say be
aggressive
when you see a problem do something
about it that's what is expected of
leaders move to a place where you can
best assess the nature of the problem
and provide guidance and resources to
resolve it as quickly as possible
and number three communicate your intent
every step of the way
I was uh I was at a team and we were
talking and and just reviewing some
tactics and stuff this may be like two
three years ago and there was they had I
got presented
with this argument of hey where should
the where should if we gotta if we got a
troop out there where should the task
unit Commander be
well we I think it should be up front
and the other guy was saying I think you
should be in the back or whatever they
were saying
and I said uh who you know what do you
think what do you think what are you
think and finally I said hey that task
unit Commander should be where he can
best like see what's going on not get
totally overwhelmed with what's
happening right in front of them
shouldn't be shouldn't have to be
handling prisoners and and shooting his
gun but he shouldn't be so far away that
he can't understand what's going on so
that's when you say move to a place
where you can best assess the nature of
the problem and provide guidance that's
it yeah you know and I think you
captured it well there you know I talk
about run to the sound of guns and and
the implication is again go to solve
problems I used to see folks more so
after I left the military but there were
times when I was uh you know in charge
of academics when I would see a problem
at a particular University and I would
call up and talk to the president
and I'd say uh okay so what do you plan
on doing about this
and they would say well you know I'm
going to let the chair or the dean or
the Provost handle this
it's like I don't think so this is this
is kind of the Washington Post test as
you mentioned you know this is this is
not good and you need to move because
you can solve this as the president
where the chair and the dean probably
can't but of course A lot of times
leaders and not just in the academic
world leaders are afraid to move to
where the problem is because they know
that then they own the problem
and so you see it in the corporate world
as well you know things get dirty and
get ugly and it's like oh I need to
distance myself from that no no that's
not what you need to do you need to move
right to where that is so that you can
Garner all the resources so that you can
make the decision so that you can solve
the problem now will you get painted
with that brush absolutely guess what
you're the leader that's part of the job
right and I I talk in there uh the story
about the Deepwater Horizon so oil rig
that blew up in the Gulf several years
ago and
um and there were you know I remember
pictures on the on the news at night you
know the mom and pop stores that were
flooded with oil the birds were relying
dead on the beach and
um and the the CEO you know was a long
ways away
in the UK and did not come to visit uh
the the site there on the on the Gulf of
Mexico
and at one point in time
uh somebody stuck a camera uh and a
microphone in his face and said you know
what are you doing why aren't you coming
to this what's going on
and the CEO said you know this this has
been really busy for the last couple
weeks you know I'm really tired of this
I just kind of want to get back to my
life
ouch ouch needless to say he did not
last as a CEO now he eventually did go
down to the gulf but it was by that time
it was too late and the point is hey
something bad happens in your
organization
boy you better move to where that
problem is quickly and um and again I I
was fortunate you know growing up in the
teams to see this time and time again
then after 9 11 of course I worked for
some remarkable Army generals and uh and
I watched Again part of the culture in
the Marines as well and you know part of
the culture for the the big generals was
hey you know Jim Mattis would be and
ramadi and in Fallujah uh Stan
McChrystal would get down in Afghanistan
Ray odierno would walk along the the
markets in Baghdad I mean these guys
understood hey before be up front and
when things go bad you're right you
don't necessarily need to have a gym
Mattis picking up a gun shooting but you
got to be in a position where you can
see what's unfolding so that you're in a
position to make the best decisions uh
to resolve the problem
but uh but once again my time in the
corporate world in the academic world I
found the same problems again this is
the book yeah I pull on Military
examples but at the end of the day this
is this is about leadership it's
fungible you know whether you're in the
military whether you're in the corporate
world whether you're in the academic
world no matter where you are
the leadership principles are the same I
used to get asked all the time you know
when I uh when I was a Chancellor at the
University of Texas I'd be talking to
large donor groups or something like
this and invariably somebody from the
back would ask what they thought was a
rhetorical question
and they would say something about the
fact that you know well you know Admiral
you know when you were in the military
of course you know you just told people
what to do and they did it but now that
you're in charge of all these faculty
you know and and they're kind of
eccentric and they don't they don't uh
you know like discipline you know how do
you deal with that how do you deal with
these people that don't just follow
orders like they did in the military
and I would pause and I'd say well let
me tell you
if you think that when I was in the
military you just told people what to do
and they did it you never spent a day in
the military because you know you know
no matter where you are in the
leadership position you have to inspire
people you have to manage people every
once while you got to kind of kick them
in the fourth point of contact but at
the end of the day this is I don't know
in my 37 years that I ever gave anyone
an order
you know again the order was implied
but leaders you've got to inspire and
you've got to manage and you've got to
to help people understand the nature of
the work they're trying to do and that's
good leadership and again so I think
those principles apply kind of wherever
you go
yeah uh two things for me number one
if your boss calls you and asks you
about a problem you need to go address
that problem so that's like if my boss
calls me and says hey jungle what's
going on with this thing I'm on it I'm
gonna go figure out what's going on let
me get that problem solved so if your
boss is calling you that's his very nice
indirect way of saying you better get
this squared away right now and yeah I I
spent uh quite a bit of time now working
with civilian companies and right out of
the gate one of the first CEOs that I
had a call with to set up I was going to
work with this company and he said you
know I just can't wait till you come up
here and whip my people into shape and I
said Hey listen if you're looking for
someone to whip your people in the shape
you should call someone else right
because if we're the whipping is what
you do to dogs and horses and slaves and
you don't get results that you want and
you definitely aren't going to form a
world-class organization so uh yes
leadership is required and now another
thing I'll tell people is you know you
think you can just tell people what to
do in the military you're telling them
to do something that might get them
killed there's actually no place where
people will push back more than when
they are being told to do something that
could get them killed that's where they
say hey you're an idiot I'm not doing it
that's what that's what happens and
actually that does get reflected in in
movies from time to time they show you
know the especially they show the
Vietnam area I'm not doing that that's
ridiculous so yeah that's uh too bad
that we have that reputation and I think
he does has come from all the boot camp
scenes right all the boot camp Series so
but you know your point about
um
yeah when things go wrong and you and I
were talking before we started the
podcast you know the nature of combat is
always challenging and unfortunately uh
we have civilian casualties
um and I can tell you you know when I
ran my Three Star Command in Iraq and
Afghanistan just the nature of you know
ten thousand uh guys out there
conducting combat operations every night
in Iraq and Afghanistan
we had civilian casualties and every
time we had these as I mentioned you
know we did a thorough thorough
investigation but when those casualties
were significant enough I mean I would
be the guy that would move to you know
the side of the casualty or I would talk
to the general you can't avoid the the
ugly problems and the uglier and the
harder they are the more you as a leader
need to be right up front
um and again will it potentially cost
you your job will it cost you your
reputation will it cost you it could
cost you all those things
but if you do it it will also gain you
the respect of the people that work for
you because they know that you took on
the hard problem uh you knew the
ramifications because you're going to
own that problem and if it turns out
that problem is really ugly and it's on
you uh yeah but the people that work for
you they expect you as a leader to get
out there to address the problems to be
the face of both the problem and the
solution
yeah that's one of one of the good
things I learned from the Army
um we had
you know we're in combat all the time
and people are getting killed and people
are getting shot and what one of the
things I learned from the Army was oh
the best thing you can do if something
happens is you say hey come investigate
this right now yeah like if something
happens Let's do an investigation
because I want to know what happened I
want to make sure everybody knows what
happened I want to see what we learned
from it and our motto one of our models
was investigate us come and investigate
us you want to see what we're doing you
want to understand what what we're doing
out here how it's happening how these
things transpire come investigate us and
and sure enough I mean number one we did
shooter statements all the time for all
of our engagements for that reason to
make sure people knew like here's
exactly what happened here's the here's
the enemy tactics techniques and
procedures that were witnessed here's
the Rules of Engagement that were
followed here's what happened and here's
how and here's here's how it happened
and then when we did uh if anything
expanded beyond that I was like yes
please come and investigate us I learned
that from the Army the army the Army
said hey if anything happens you should
raise your hand and say investigate and
that's the best possible thing to do get
someone else down here because if you
look like if you look like you got your
hand down and you're looking in the
other direction and you're saying I
don't want to get investigated
you you're you're gonna you're gonna
sound guilty and there's probably a
reason that you're gonna sound guilty
probably because you're doing something
stupid so we would raise our hand Yep
this is what happened come investigate
come and check it out come and give us
your two cents we want to know that you
know what's happening right so I love
that attitude it's also a really good
attitude that everybody in my everyone
that works for me knows that that's my
attitude like every single person knows
what I'm gonna do there's not gonna be
any cover-ups we're not you know I
literally said hey where there will be
no cover-ups if you work for me there's
nothing getting covered up if you think
I'm gonna brush something on the rug it
ain't happening if you're doing
something stupid it's going to come out
so don't do anything stupid you know our
Rules of Engagement hey you better make
sure if you if you kill somebody you
better make sure that they are bad
if they're not bad don't kill them
obviously and we put those rules out and
that's how we executed that's how we
operated so I really like that idea up
and down the chain of command come
investigate us
um next one to a sponty am I saying that
right she was fonte that's right sue a
spontane see how it wasn't saying it
quite red if I put an e in there the
Rangers have a Latin saying sua sponte
it means of your own accord in other
words doing what needs to be done
without being told to do so there is
often misguided belief that soldiers
only follow orders but the strength of
the American Military is that the great
Soldiers the truly great leaders do what
is right without being told they do what
is right to protect their men and women
they do what is right to uphold the
reputation of their unit they do what is
right to bring honor to their country
they do what needs to be done whether
ordered to do so or not this sense of
initiative separates the great leaders
from the mediocre ones
yes I start off that chapter talking
about Ralph Puckett Ralph Puckett who
received the Medal of Honor for actions
uh Army Ranger received the Medal of
Honor for actions in Korea and then I
think also received the distinguished
service cross in Vietnam highly
decorated guy
but the story I think that is that is
almost more compelling as strange as it
sounds because you know in the case of
Ralph Puckett uh the Rangers are moving
into this position in Korea they're
taking fire
um from the North Koreans and the
Chinese and Puckett in order to draw the
enemy's fire so that the Rangers can
direct fire on the enemy runs across an
open field not once not twice not three
times but but four or five times so the
Rangers can find out where the fire is
coming from and then as soon as they see
where the the North Korean Gunners are
then they engage them right and uh and
at some point in time later on years
later somebody uh was asked why the hell
did Ralph Puckett do that and the young
Ranger replied well somebody had to do
it and Lieutenant Puckett knew that he
was at somebody he kind of did it of his
own accord
but I tell a much simpler story because
obviously you know we're not all going
to find ourselves in the Ralph bucket
position where you know our lives are at
stake uh but but this idea is is still
important this idea of suas fonty of
your own accord
and I mentioned that uh when I was
Commodore
we were
um commemorating a building in Hawaii
for Moki Martin for one of the great
seals Lieutenant Philip belmoki Martin
Moki was born and raised in Hawaii and
in this building for sdv building we
were
um kind of name the building his honor
well as we as we get up to do this we've
got the hangar the high Bay is full we
got you know a couple hundred folks are
there you got dignitaries from um from
Hawaii there and so uh and Loki as you
know is in a wheelchair
um so I get up to give my comments and
we had correctly positioned the
microphone for Moki to give his comments
but we had not positioned it absolutely
correctly so Moki wheels up to give his
remarks and and you can't hear him
and I'm I'm kind of sitting in the back
and and I'm thinking okay well I'm I'm
the senior officer I'm the dignitary
here it's going to be a little awkward
but I think I need to get up and go
reposition the microphone sounds like a
small thing except now everybody is kind
of you can tell they're not so as I
start to get up out of my seat all of a
sudden the young seal from formation
breaks formation
comes out walks past the 200 people
comes right up to Loki Martin promptly
salutes him
adjust the microphone steps back again
salutes him again does an about face and
returns to formation
and we didn't miss a word of moki's
comments
small thing you know not life or death
but it was the importance of the event
this this was meaningful and this young
seal
knew something had to be done
so you know nobody told him to do it it
was of his own accord nobody said hey
you need to break formation to go fix
that mic no he just said hey you know
what and by the way not the senior guy
of course I was a senior guy I wasn't
even the senior guy in the formation I
think he was young second class petty
officer but he knew something had to be
done so my point to the reader is look
this isn't always about life and death
none of these things are about life and
death theft before dishonor is you know
that's a saying but it's about just
being honorable
um but in this case uh susponte is if
you're a leader and you see something
that needs to be done
do it don't you don't always have to ask
if it's the right thing to do just move
out and do it but as you know people are
like I don't know I don't know maybe I
shouldn't do this maybe you go do it
that's what good leaders do yes uh
putting up putting a seal troop through
Urban combat and there's been total
chaos going on there's paintball flying
everywhere
explosions going off Humvees are in
ditches it's just total Mayhem and
there's there's this one kid he's an E5
at the time I still know he's a freaking
awesome guy but he's knee five and I've
been watching him through land Warfare
and Washington see I knew he was a
squared away guy
and so he's sitting behind this wall you
know paintball flying over everywhere
and I kind of walk over to him I go hey
bro and he looks up at me and I go what
do you guys think he should do right now
what do you think he should do right now
and he goes we go get in that building
man strong point that building and I go
freaking make it happen and he looked at
me with like big eyes like wait a second
I can do that
and I go do it and so he goes everyone
strong point that building right there
and boom all of a sudden all these
troops start to pass the word and they
all strong point that building in a
carry on but it was that idea that this
kid he's an E5 he shouldn't be making
big tactical decisions but that's what
the freaking seals are for right that's
what you're supposed to do you see what
you need to make happen make it happen
[Laughter]
uh Who Dares win who dares wins we
brought this one up
um
clearly an important one
you could say this in 1991 I was a
student at the Naval Postgraduate School
in Monterey California for two years I
worked on developing a theory of Special
Operations I wanted to know why Special
Operations Mission succeeded in spite of
the fact that they were exceptionally
high risk was their boldness alone
enough to carry the day where their
Commandos so superior to the enemy that
they were bound to win in a fight was
their technology so exceptional that it
gave them an overwhelming Advantage as
it turned out those factors were
necessary but certainly not sufficient
for success in each case who dares wins
had to be backed up
by who plans and prepares wins it was
only through extensive planning and
preparation that the Special Operations
leaders were able to identify the major
risk factors and develop options for
addressing them to those on the outside
looking in the risks appeared great
however to those on the inside the risks
were manageable
every great leader must exhibit some
sense of boldness because the rank and
file don't want to follow a timid Soul
those leaders must be prepared to act
when others are weak need and fearful of
failure they must Embrace The Motto who
dares wins but
no leader should confuse daring and
audacity with brashness and impudence
the former is fine the latter will
surely result in failure
so well it goes back to the discussion
we just had earlier you know when when
you were when your platoon was looking
at taking rescuing the sausage same
thing you know you look at it and you
say there is a whole lot of risk here
and there's going to be some guys that
say and we're gonna go
no you need to take counsel your fears
but you also need to kind of plan your
way through the hard part so whether
it's breaching the heavy breach in the
gate whether it's making sure you got
the ISR overhead so you know what paths
and of course you know I saw this every
every night in Iraq and Afghanistan
where you are always worried as you know
about pressure plate Minds about IEDs
but if you put a pred overhead or a
Reaper or something and you watched it
long enough and you would see them kind
of in and out of the buildings you know
the seals and the Rangers on my end they
would map it out you know okay so we
know this is a clear path because we've
seen the women and children walking
along this path oh by the way we've
never seen anybody walking over here
that may not be a good place to be
um but but this idea is yeah who dares
when you have to be
audacious you have to have a little
Swagger I always tell leaders look you
know like I said nobody wants to follow
somebody that's too tempted every leader
needs to have a little bit of swagger
that's okay
but you know hubris and and being a
little bit too Cavalier with the lives
of your men and women now that's not
okay uh have a little Swagger but back
it up with hard planning hard rehearsals
good discipline all the sorts of things
that are really going to make it
successful
um and then maybe you can Swagger a
little more after after you're
successful Yeah you mentioned uh how in
the movies
they never show the planning they never
show the guys at the Whiteboard they
never show the you know four hour
discussion about what the best approach
to take is they also don't show the
months and months and years and years of
standard operating procedure that gets
developed and I know uh going back to my
first deployment to Iraq
so we're there and when we first showed
up there there's only one platoon in
Iraq and it was it was us so it was
awesome and then my you know my command
started showing up and I had a great
relationship with my commanding officer
who is also my executive officer at Team
two so we had a great relationship I'll
Stoke from show up and we're there for a
while now we're sort of you know we're
doing a lot we're working on all the
time we're working every night
and at some point you know somebody
asked him a question he said uh he
wanted to know hey Jocko how much time
do you need to be able to launch on a
Target
because you know there this is we we'd
gotten past when the war started it was
like oh wait 96 hour planning cycle and
that kind of thing so now we're way past
that but so you know he comes down to
talk to me and he says Hey Jocko like yo
we're getting asked CJ sotif wants to
know how long do you need before you can
launch on the target
and I I look at him I go uh 15 minutes
you know and he kind of like was a
little bit surprised and of course
thought I had you know like a little bit
maybe extra Swagger but but and I
explained it then I sat down I said Hey
sir here's the deal like we know what
we're gonna do you point us at a
building it's not a plan it's a standard
operating procedure this is what we're
gonna do and if you tell me where the
target is you tell me what frequency the
conventional forces are that are in that
AO and where the friendly forces are
located that's the information I need
you tell me go hit a Target I can we can
leave in 15 minutes that's how long it
takes me to get my battle dress on and
so it takes me 15 minutes and we'll be
in those Humvees rolling but all of that
wasn't based on our planning it was
based on the fact that our standard
operating procedures were so solid at
that because we were running off
Saturday night we know what we're gonna
do so those those are included too yeah
and and it's uh you know when I tell
people a lot about the bin Laden raid I
said look we went through the standard
as you know our our procedures at that
command very very detailed before any
Mission and the the night before the
mission I do a four-hour debrief and so
as the commander everybody that's part
of the mission is there and you know
they all come up to me I'm sitting in
the front row in the hangar and uh and
they said you know sir I'm uh chief
petty officer so-and-so here's what I'm
doing and of course we got the model in
front of us sir my job is do this this
and then I quiz them and I check him so
but
of course no plan survives first Contact
right so the idea you know we had the
you know first year was going to come in
guys are going to faster open in the
courtyard second Hilo is going to come
in guys going to faster Up on the Roof
none of that plays out
and of course we had plan a we had Plan
B we had plan C but also you talk about
the standard operating procedures Team
guys knew what to do okay look now we
are not where we thought we were going
to be we're not even in the same
compound we're isolated oh by the way
the second group is outside the building
well we didn't plan on being outside but
you know what we've been outside a lot
of compounds in our time right of course
every one of these guys a lot of combat
experience so the Sops then kick in okay
I got it breacher breach this wall guys
know how they're going to flow in
everybody knows how they're going to
clear the rooms and the Sops kind of
take over after you know plan a b and c
um so yeah the the but this is what a
lot of folks don't understand but if
you're a brand spanking new platoon
you don't have that muscle memory on the
Sops you know particularly if you've got
new guys in the platoon but after like
your platoon like after you've been in
combat for a while and every night it's
another building in ramadi and it's uh
you know exactly if you go into the
carport you're going to enter into the
kitchen uh because ever again in Iraqi
house has got the kitchen off the
carport
um you know this is these are Sops
but it's when all of a sudden the target
becomes different than what the Sops
have called for and that was the case in
the bin Laden raid the other compound
large trapezoid but it was just a little
bit different than what we'd expected
um you know kind of from the standard
compounds boy then you got to plan the
heck out of it
yeah yeah
the uh
we got really good as a community in
those 20s yes
we did
um next one hope is not a strategy
uh never underestimate the power of Hope
and again I'm fast forwarding get the
book get the book for all the examples
I've given some of them not giving all
of them never an estimate the power of
hope hope is what inspires hope and what
encourages hope is what empowers and
without hope nothing would be nothing
worthwhile can be accomplished
but hope alone is just wishful thinking
pair hope with this sound strategy a
detailed plan and a lot of hard work and
nothing is Out Of Reach
I tell people pretty regularly without
hope nothing can be accomplished but
hope by itself accomplishes nothing yeah
you know when I was doing writing my
thesis at the Naval Postgraduate School
the one that became Spec Ops
I had a chance to interview some of the
you know the great leaders of the World
War II missions in particular
and and one of them was the mission to
go get the terpits terpitz was a huge
German battleship it had been slightly
damaged and had been sent up in the
cathyard up into Norway where the the
Brits could not get to it
so for two years uh the British uh
decide that they're going to build a
plan using x-craft so xcraft were these
three-man small dry submarines they're
going to send six of them from Scotland
across the Open Sea to get into the
Fjord to make their way up to up the
long way up the Fjord to put large
explosives on the battleship turpits and
sink it so for two years they rehearsed
this
well in the planning the little
submarines were being pulled by big
submarines and back in the day they had
two kinds of lines
they had standard Manila lines kind of
cotton woven big houses big lines and
they had this new thing called nylon the
nylon ropes well as as they rehearse
this again they had a almost almost two
years to rehearse this they never did a
full dress rehearsal in Towing the
little mini subs because when the mini
subs towed behind the big submarine they
would they would oscillate up and down
and the guys got violently sick in the
back of these little mini subs they
could only handle it for about an hour
and a half and they said you know what
when the time comes we'll gut it up and
we'll it was like a seven or eight hour
Transit across they said we'll just
we'll get it up so they never rehearsed
that part of it
well when the mission finally came about
the six big submarines Towing the six
mini subs three of them are sunk and
lost before they ever get to Norway
because the Manila lines broke
because they didn't
test it out to its full extent all the
nylon lines held and the point of that
and I I as I talked to the a guy named
Godfrey Place Lieutenant Godfrey Place
who successfully got his ex-graft up the
Fjord and actually blew up the USS
terpits damaged it enough that it never
sailed again
but in in talking to him he said you
know if only we had done a full dress
rehearsal if only we had planned that
part in it and really done and executed
and rehearsed that full part of the plan
we'd have known the Manila lines were
going to break and we probably would
have saved nine guys
and and he carried that burden even when
I interviewed him back in the 90s I mean
it was like we had two years and we
never did a full dress rehearsal on that
and it is about this they again they
hoped
they hoped it would all work
and but hope wasn't the right strategy
if they had planned and rehearsed it
they would have known that part was
going to fail
um and you know you see it all the time
like I said I tell leaders all the time
look it's great to be inspirational it's
really important to be inspirational
it's important to give the men and women
that work for you hope and Inspire them
but if that's all you're bringing it
probably ain't gonna work you better be
also prepared to pull out the stubby
pencil and do the hard planning build
the Tactical plan the Strategic plan
figure out how it's all going to work
together because that's what's expected
of a leader uh at any level
I hope it's definitely not a course of
action that's for sure uh similar no
plan survives first contact with the
Enemy
um again you you just mentioned this but
you covered more in depth on the in the
book you talk about the bin Laden raid
you talk about the multiple
contingencies that they had to go
through in order and to be prepared for
those and then to execute them on
execute on them
and you say here as a leader always
ensure that your organization has put
forth the effort to plan for the worst
case scenario even if it seems the least
likely to happen because no plan
survives first contact with the enemy
always be ready
yeah I mean as you know this is
everybody always you know sometimes
you'll look at the worst case scenario
and I've seen it before more again more
outside the military because military
understands looking at a plan for the
worst case scenario
um but outside the military sometimes
they they look at it because it's going
to cost them money to plan for the worst
case scenario
so a lot of times like I mean what's the
chance of this happening so I think in
there I talk about the Exxon Valdez a
little bit the the tanker that sunk uh
off off Alaska
when they when they did the forensics
and they did the after action I did the
investigation there were a lot of people
that thought and this could happen this
could happen yeah but you know the
chance of it happening is really really
slam and in order for us to prepare for
it it's going to require a lot of people
a lot of planning a lot of money so it
was such a small percentage of chances
that I thought it could happen that they
never planned for the worst case
scenario so
now again this is the nature of it you
got to figure out how far down do you
plan I mean there's you know there's
always a worse worst case scenario but
you know in the military we know like I
said no plan survives first contact with
the Enemy you better have a plan A and A
Plan B and you better think through the
worst case scenarios so that you're
prepared to make the decisions I don't
say in Arizona the bin Laden raid I had
a decision Matrix that I had the guys
make up for me
and I said every step of the way
if this bad things happen if this bad
thing happens what am I going to do I
don't have to be thinking about it and
and debating it you know right in the
middle of the mission I want to know and
so we had one so you know if the
helicopters uh you know cross into
Pakistan and they're detected do we keep
moving or do we turn around and the
answer was if they're detected On the
Border we turn around how about a
quarter of the way through we turn
around how about halfway through we turn
around how about past halfway through so
then there were a couple branches of
that which was have the have the
pakistanis do they know where we're
going and if the answer was no then we
Press On
what happens if we lose a helicopter do
we keep going I mean what happens if we
have a mass casualty do we so all of
these scenarios I had so that In the
Heat of the battle I didn't go oh man I
don't know what do you think we should
do that's not the time to be thinking
through the most you know worst case
scenario you better have figured out
what you're going to do at that point in
time and and so I thought about
particularly the mass casualty what
happens if one helicopter goes down what
happens if two helicopters go down and
we've we've got 24 seals dead on the
ground or injured well I had a backup
plan for that right we had a whole
contingency of guys waiting in
Afghanistan to come pull them out
but um but I wanted to make sure I
didn't waffle on any of those decisions
so when it was warm and cozy I said this
is the right decision to make if things
go south
and I will know what to do in the heat
of the battle when bad things happen
because I'll have thought through it
ahead of time
this is uh when people are climbing at
Everest or whatever you know Peak that
they're climbing and they say hey if we
haven't gotten to this point or whatever
it is at 10 o'clock in the morning we're
turning around going back down no matter
where we are could be 50 meters away
we're 10 o'clock we're turning around
going back down and when people don't
follow their what they've set up that's
when they get killed you know it's
another thing I used to teach guys was
you know you're on patrol you're you're
out in the city or you're out in the
jungle you're out in the desert as a
leader you should be looking okay if we
get contacted right now where we're
gonna go because this is going to change
every 20 yards that you walk and if
you're constantly thinking oh there's a
good out over there there's some High
Ground over there you're constantly
thinking through that as soon as you do
get hit with something you already
thought through it you it so this is the
idea of just having the pre-thought
you've thought through 97 of the
information sure there could be some
three percent that well the helicopter
went down but it went down over here and
it actually landed okay and so now we've
got some people you can make some little
Minor Adjustments but the vast majority
of your thinking which is going to cause
all kinds of smoke to come out of your
ears a vast majority of it's already
done and you have a little three percent
to make a decision on and you can do it
very quickly
um number 11. pays to be a winner
I used to be a winner and as they say in
buds it also sucks to be a loser you are
on board a ship at this point I'm going
to read a quick story at zero eight
hundred I heard my name and I think
you're on deployment yeah you're on
deployment on a ship you know with a
platoon
at zero 800 I'd heard my name broad
broadcast across the ship's intercom
Commander mcraven report to the bridge
this was not a good sign I knew that the
Commodore my boss would be waiting to
grill me as I made my way from the
birthing area up three flights of
ladders to the bridge I started to
prepare my defense yes seals had gotten
into trouble
but how did that compare to the 22
Marines who were equally egregious
entering the bridge I found Mike kamatos
chromatos commodos the Commodore sitting
in his captain's chair I approached the
chair and came to a modified attention
sir you called for me kamados got down
from the chair and I could see the anger
in his face a Vietnam era Hilo pilot he
was tactically brilliant and over the
course of the past 18 months I had come
to deeply respect him for his leadership
of the amphibious ready group to this
day I count Mike kamatis as one of the
finest Leaders with whom I ever served
only five foot five he closed the
distance between us and glared up at me
just inches from my face one of your
seals got into a bar fight last night
and beat up a couple of Marines this is
entirely unacceptable
yes I completely agree I started and
then I made a fatal mistake but sir I
would also note that 22 Marines got in
trouble last night
before I could continue kamado's moved
toe-to-toe his face now fully flushed
with anger their young marines bill I
expect them to get in trouble
and then I was reminded why I was a Navy
SEAL but I hold you and your seals to a
higher standard and I expect you as
their leader to do the same are we clear
I hold you and your seals to a higher
standard those words resonated in my
head for the rest of my career while as
seal as a seal organization we have
occasionally failed to meet those high
standards and dealt with the painful
embarrassing aftermath we have never
stopped raising the bar and trying to be
the best and I have always known that as
a leader in this community my job was to
ensure the standards of conduct and
professionalism were met
which meant not only establishing the
standards but holding people accountable
he's getting in trouble yeah this was uh
we had pulled into Subic Bay
um and it was it was the deployment that
ended up being Desert Shield and Desert
Storm
but you know we've been at sea for 30
days crossing the Pacific on on the USS
Okinawa and the Fort McHenry and of
course the team guys got in and they got
out of Liberty and that didn't go so
well
but
I found out about that and so I went to
the EXO to find out who else got in
trouble that night you know and of
course I find out that okay one seal got
in trouble but 22 Marines got in trouble
and I thought this was going to be a
great defense until you know Commodore
Commodus made sure I understood
like you're a Navy SEAL
we hold you to a higher standard
and we ought to expect to be held to a
higher standard and as I point out the
book yeah you know uh We've we've made
it in the press a lot lately for not
upholding the standard but I tell people
all the time I got it you know some
people don't meet the standard but the
standard of conduct the standard of
professionalism
the standard of duty honor and Country
is I would offer as high as it's ever
been
and we expect people to meet that
standard and when they don't and some of
them don't then you gotta hold them
accountable
and every great organization every great
organization I don't again I keep
bringing back this point but it doesn't
matter what the organization is nobody
is looking for a mediocre organization
you don't say hey where is that mediocre
organization that's what I want to join
I want to go I want to go be mediocre
like those people over there everybody
wants to be part of a great organization
how do you become a great organization
you set the high standards and you hold
people accountable to those standards
now you got to give them the training
you got to give them the resources you
got to give them the latitude to do the
job
but you set high standards and you hold
people accountable that's how you make a
great organization and so if you're not
prepared to set the standards and hold
people accountable then you're never
going to have a good organization a
great organization and after a while
people won't be part of you because you
will have had you'll become a mediocre
organization
um and this idea you know it pays to be
a winner as you well know and I don't
know whether it's a term that they still
throw out because not having been to
buds in a while but you know it was
every instructor would get on your case
about you know in my case Mr back pays
to be a winner as you know there was a
Veiled Threat behind that too which was
you know if you're not a winner you're a
loser and you're going to pay the price
you're gonna have the Goon Squad you're
gonna have circus whatever comes next
but in my mind it was all about look how
do you become a winner
a winner means I said you're a great
organization you're a great person
you're a great whatever great leader and
you become a winner by setting high
standards and holding people accountable
um and that again that served me well
but when Commodus called me up and I
tried to defend the fact that well we
were just as good as the Marines maybe
even a little bit it was like no that's
not the point
you're the Navy Seals my expectation for
Navy Seals is that you're the best and
if you're going to be the best this type
of behavior is unacceptable and um and
he was right he was right
Jack
next one a Shepherd should smell like
his sheep
and um and this one you tell a great
story you're on a midshipmen tour you're
on the USS alette
and you meet a sailor named Ricky I try
to find his his uh Rank and his what his
rate was he must I think he worked in
the boiler room he was he was a second
class meeting there you go boiler Tech
and
um
you say so you're there you're young
midship and you're not even a
commissioned officer yet and you're
experiencing what it's like to be in the
fleet your your introduction to him is
when you step on his head or his face or
something while he's trying to sleep and
you're trying to get in your bunk and
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit but
you say knowing I would someday be
wearing Ensign bars Ricky and his other
crewmates made sure I understood what
they expected from their officers
that dude Ricky said referring to a
young Lieutenant he shows up every day
and spends an hour in the boiler room
with me now that's a good officer bro
the EXO he's a hard ass when he wants to
be but he cuts us some slack when he can
he's good too the skipper rides us hard
but he always makes sure we get the best
spot on the pier
the officers they respected the most
were the ones who showed up in the
Boiler Room when it gets when it was 120
degrees who got greasy and turned
wrenches with them who picked up a broom
and helped with the evening sweep down
who brought them water when they were
painting the side of the ship and who
thanked them routinely for their efforts
but they also wanted an officer who made
the tough decisions held them
accountable worked hard and above all
they want an officer who valued them for
their tough work they did finally they
wanted an officer they could be proud of
even if they didn't say it publicly they
wanted someone who was smart athletic
looked good in their uniform and didn't
embarrass them on Liberty by getting too
drunk or too rowdy
three years later I was commissioned as
an Ensign in the Navy and headed off to
some two basic underwater demolition
SEAL training
the lessons from my time with Ricky were
never far from my mind share the misery
share the dangers share the camaraderie
listen to their stories and you will
learn about your Sailors and you will
learn what they expect from you
you know I tell folks I think this is
the single most important lesson I ever
learned even before I got to the teams
so the Navy again in its in its wisdom
back then in between your freshman and
sophomore year they sent you on what
they euphemistically called the cruise
and as you point out I was on the USS
OLED it was a fast frigate
and so here you are as a prospective
officer
but they want you to understand what it
means to be a sailor so for seven weeks
I'm living with the sailors
um you know cleaning the heads I'm
buffing the floors I'm doing all the
things Sailors do so that you can
understand
the impact of your decisions as an
officer every decision you make as an
officer is going to affect that sailor
at the deck plate level and you better
understand that relationship and
somebody later on talked to me about
professional distance
and the importance of professional
distance and the idea was like sometimes
as we go through SEAL training you know
that professional distance that distance
between the decision makers and the rank
and file maybe gets a little too close
but if you ever get to the point where
you're sitting in your office drinking
coffee while the troops are out you know
on the battlefield then that
professional distance has gotten way too
way too wide you need to make sure that
that professional distance whether
you're an Ensign or a four-star Admiral
is such that you understand how the
decisions that you're making are
affecting the men and women that you're
you're serving and it can never get too
far but also you got to be careful about
it getting too close because you're
going to have to make the hard tough
decisions sometimes decisions that are
affecting your friendships that are
affecting guys families there may be
affecting guys lives
but sometimes you got to make that
decision and if you're too close
sometimes that becomes challenging but
this idea that the seven weeks I spent
with uh with Ricky and the other Sailors
on the USS olet was a time I had never
forgot because it was just this
recognition that it is about the sailors
it's always about the sailors and making
sure the sailors can run the ship run
the platoon whatever the organization is
and it really is this reflection I think
about servant leadership as well as you
know we when I first came into the
military in 1977 there weren't a lot of
what we recall servant leaders it still
had for the Navy it had this kind of
surface Warfare mentality which was you
know the CEO of the ship was the king
whatever the CEO said you were going to
do and and it was a heart the young
officers were put in crucibles and if
they Survived The Crucible then I guess
they were going to be a decent officer
then they all volunteer military comes
into effect and there were a lot of guys
said I don't have to put up with this
crap anymore you know I can't be yelled
at constantly and this idea that look as
a servant leader
your job is to make sure that the team
is successful that once again you know
you give the men and women that work for
you the tools do the job you give them
the training do the job you give them
the latitude do the job you hold them
accountable when they don't do the job
but if the leadership ever becomes about
you if it's about your promotion if it's
about your ego it's about your glory
you're probably not the right person for
the job I mean this is I tell folks all
the time we're called the SEAL Teams for
a reason
because it's about the team you can't
get the job done unless the team does it
and if a leader if if you're not
inspiring that team if you're not
managing that team if you haven't come
up with a good plan if they're not
prepared to follow you
then it isn't going to work so this was
a again a marvelous lesson early on in
my career and uh and the Navy still does
those Cruises have gotten a lot shorter
unfortunately because of money but uh
best seven weeks I think I spent
learning leadership and it was about
learning about the troops yeah and it's
awesome that people ask me who's your
Mentor people ask me that and I always
say well I have all kinds of managers I
have mentors that are books you know my
biggest Mentor is Colonel David
hackworth who I never met but I just
read his books and stole everything from
him you know that that's who the mentors
are and here you are young ants and
you're getting mentored by this you know
B bt2 in the U.S Navy
how long
I'm thinking of the uh the abusive
tyrannical authoritarian officer in the
fleet and then you end up with this like
cycle of of of violence you know cycle
of abuse and that's how I got treated so
that's what I'm gonna treat the next guy
did you get to see that sort of you know
as the volunteer Navy came on board did
you did you watch that transition I did
and uh you know the teams were never
quite like that because the commanding
officers I had in the teams because
again we'd all gone to buds together so
there was a little bit of a different
leadership uh mentality from the
commanding officers in the teams but
some of those commanding officers had
been ship drivers at some point in time
but I spent a lot of time early on as I
mentioned I was on amphibious ready
group but I spent time on carriers and
submarines and early on in my career
there was a little bit of this you know
tyrannical sort of commanding officer
that that's the way they were trained
you know they were trained to yell and
scream and and that was the expectation
in the 80s things began to change a
little bit and a lot of this was the
Vietnam officers and I think the guys
like Colin Powell and I think about
Norman Schwarzkopf the army guys that
had come out of Vietnam said hey look we
got to change the approach to how we
lead and I don't know when the term
servant leadership began to apply but
yeah I did see this change over time uh
this recognition that hey no guess what
as a leader you just don't tell people
what to do and they do it
you've got to once again you've got to
inspire you've got to be out there with
the men and women your Sailors your
soldiers your airman's Marines
the Army understood this I think because
it was more part of the army culture
than it was the big Navy culture because
you know in Navy there's officers
country and there's a there's a distance
between the officers and the sailors
even though again don't misunderstand me
there were some fabulous absolutely
fabulous commanding officers and
officers on ships and submarines that
understood that they had to earned the
respect of the sailors so don't
misunderstand that part but in general
there was a little bit of a separation
whereas the army officers the Marine
officers who were in Vietnam I mean
they're in the mud with the with the
troops and so they had there was a
little bit of a different leadership
style there and so as the 70s and the
80s and then the 90s came along you saw
this this transition between the hard
ass Co to the co that yeah you still
need to be hard ass because oh by the
way you're driving a ship but you got to
earn the respect
you don't get the respect just because
you're the commanding officer you got to
earn the respect every day and you got
to figure out the best way to do that by
the time 9 11 comes along
I think what I saw by that time and it's
why we were I think you know again I've
said before
you know we are the finest military I
think in the history of the world and
you think back on all the great
militaries whether you go back to the
Roman Legions uh World War II would not
make any difference
I don't know of any force that stayed
together and fought for 20 years
straight 20 years I mean you think about
your time Jaco think about all the guys
you know particularly these guys that
came in right after 9 11 that signed up
after 9 11 knowing they were going to
war
and they stayed for 20 years and they
did 15 18 I don't know how many
deployments constantly at War and your
point about the Sops the standard
operating procedures
after a while you could pull any platoon
with the guys together who'd been
spending time in Iraq and Afghanistan
and say okay we've got to Target how
many minutes do you need I need 15
minutes why because they've done it so
many times before
most of the Roman Legions of course were
kind of part-time troops uh you know you
had some professionals but they were
only Professionals for a couple of years
they drew on the farmers a lot of times
to make the Roman Legions you think
about World War II incredible uh
Americans
the war only lasted for four years a lot
of these guys were on the line for maybe
you know 30 days on 30 days off maybe 18
months in in Europe or or uh or the
Pacific
these guys were you know 20 years yeah
in combat
um yeah from 18 19 20 years old up until
they're 42 43 44. and so the so the
leadership had to change and now you
know not every leader changed not every
leader got the memo
um you know we still had some kind of
hard asses out there that didn't
understand we needed to leave but I was
fortunate again in my time as a Navy
officer essentially serving in the Army
as you know and my joint command I
watched these really remarkable General
officers I remember one point in time a
young Army Major wrote some scathing
critique of the army leadership
and um at the senior Army leadership in
Iraq and Afghanistan and frankly I was I
was pretty livid looking at the article
and this was kind of the as I've said
before the junior officer righteousness
you know uh the generals are sitting up
there in their play they just don't
understand you know they're up there
drinking their coffee and the hard work
is being done well let me tell you every
General officer I knew Army Marine and
then the Navy flag officers were in
there they understood what the troops
were going through they had this
tremendous respect for the troops and
the great ones again the Petraeus
odierno uh the mccrystal the McKiernan I
mean these guys would get down you know
and oh by the way they were in their 50s
and yet they would go out with the guys
they would put themselves In Harm's Way
because they respected the troops so
much
um and that was a certain amount of
servant leadership it was this
recognition that hey I'm in charge but
you know what I gotta earn the respect
every single day and the only way you're
going to earn the respect do the hard
work
share the fear again share the the
discomfort just like Ricky told me come
to the boiler room you know share the
hazards share the discomfort spend time
with the troops that's how you're in
their respect and part of that is the
next uh section troop the line uh
trooping the line is steeped in Army
tradition historically generals have
ordered their soldiers to muster on the
parade field so the officers could
inspect the troops ask questions about
their training and ensure the General's
orders were being relayed to the
youngest private in the formation
you gotta talk to your people yeah and
find out what's going on so I mentioned
there so when I was over in Afghanistan
and Iraq but I think in this particular
example I'm talking about Afghanistan
and generally I'd stay in The Jock until
uh you know most of the guys were kind
of on their way home or something and
then I would walk around at night and it
was normally so Afghan time was probably
like four or five in the morning Afghan
time but we were on Zulu time so it was
always at 11 30 12 o'clock
and I would get you know every evening
I'd kind of walk around and talk to the
the soldiers now for your listeners
while our special operations force was
on this kind of Camp Alpha most of the
soldiers that were supporting us were
you know conventional soldiers who
frankly didn't have a clue who we were
they were man in the guard towers or
they were you know running the
laundromats or they were up on the motor
pool but but they didn't know what we
were doing day in and day out
but in this one particular time as I
tell the story I'm wandering around and
I remember going into the laundromat and
so we we had this uh you know plywood
building that the Seabees had built long
typical laundromat right just like you
see in the civilian world I don't know
20 30 laundromats in there and about
half of them weren't working
and so I come in about two o'clock in
the morning uh you know and you know the
soldiers are bitching about the fact
that you know damn laundry's not working
of course I come in they see me oh sir
how are you let's go let's go I hope so
everything's going fine
laundromat laundry machines aren't
working yeah interesting so the next day
I've got my Global video teleconference
you know and you know so here I am
talking the entire force thousands of
people on the video teleconference and
they're waiting for you know the great
Admiral to give them some guidance on
winning the war in Iraq and Afghanistan
and so I kind of go down the saying I
said okay
I said I want all the senior ncos that
are kind of in charge of the the
Cantonment area The Garrison go check
the laundromats and you know I can see
the eyes rolling on the on the video
light are you kidding me the three star
is telling the ncos to get the laundry
machines fixed
but the point was you find out about
things when you troop the line
maybe it wasn't going to save the war
but it was going to save the morale a
little bit of the soldiers that were
working for me so we got the laundromats
fixed we got a bunch of things fixed and
that's important to an organization when
I was the chancellor at the University
of Texas system I built this kind of
electronic suggestion box
and I would watch it every day the the
and the people could add anonymously you
know those things all screwed up or this
at one point in time I kept seeing this
thread come up
and it was about the paper towels
paper towels so we we worked in this big
office building
and it turns out somebody said well
these are like soviet-style paper towels
rough you know I'm like
so all of a sudden more and more
comments kept coming in about the paper
towels
and so I'm thinking to myself I am the
chancellor of the University of Texas
system in charge of 230 000 men and a
hundred thousand I am gonna fix the
paper towel problem right and so I get a
hold of the guy who's essentially my
Logistics office I said look get new
paper towels and of course I think it's
going to be an easy decision he's like
ah sir it's not quite that easy we buy
bulk I said so we go fine I said okay I
don't care if I got to pay for the
freaking paper towels we're getting new
paper towels in so I finally get the
paper towel problem fixed
it was very interesting dynamic
the rank and file the employees thought
you know here's the chancellor who I got
it he is solving big problems with the
universities but he also cared enough to
get the paper towel problem fixed now
you know as a leader you don't always
have a chance to worry about paper
towels you know that's what the that's
what the sergeants do and that's what
the petty officers do but every once in
a while in a large organization you find
that little problem that seems
intractable that nobody else seems to be
able to fix I mean the laundromats have
been broken for a long time you know and
the paper towels had been Sylvia style
paper towels for about a year or so
and you fix that problem and the troops
then understand and he's listening to us
he cares about the little problems
wasn't going to save the world but we
got the Soviet paper towels fixed and
interestingly enough it the rank and
file were very appreciative just like
the soldiers were a priest if that all
of a sudden the laundromats worked you
know so you can do those sorts of things
when you troop the line yeah you you
wrap this one up you say get out of your
office and talk to employees at the far
end of the chain of command find an
opportunity to solve small but seemingly
intractable problems ensure your senior
staff know that these little problems
can have major effects on morale
next section
expect what you inspect and you've got a
story in here about the Sante raid
and uh the commander of that rate we
actually had a guy a Sante Raider on the
podcast yep Terry buckler
um podcast 329 Terry buckler he was
brand new in Special Forces and his
first operation was the Sante raid and
his entire time in Vietnam was 20
minutes as the song one of the Sante
Raiders he got off of the helicopter and
killed a dude in like 10 steps I'm like
you have the the best uh shortest time
to contact of anyone I mean that's just
like unbelievable yeah this he he just
joined right at the end of the Vietnam
War and boom there you go Sante raid uh
but uh Colonel Elliott Bud cindor who we
talked about on that podcast he was the
GFC on the on the Sante raid and he
ended up in another job he was running
the Convoy security for sensitive
material and you got a quick story in
here about that
uh cindor had relinquished oversight of
the mission to the senior federal agents
or agent a police captain the agent was
now in charge and would oversee the
actual movement of the material this is
like a big Convoy that's happening as
cindor observed the final preparations
for movement one thing caught his
attention at no time had the captain
conducted a Personnel inspection of each
guard on the truck he approached the
agent and tactfully said I'm sorry
Captain but I noticed you didn't conduct
a Personnel inspection of your troops
the captain looking somewhat annoyed
rolled his eyes and said well Colonel
we're all professionals here there's no
need for an inspection
cindor a man of quiet disposition but
with a penchant for detail replied
pointedly well Captain if you're a real
professional you would understand the
value of an inspection
Captain paused remembering the service
of the man in front of him and within
minutes each agent was lined up as the
captain went by Man by man to ensure all
their equipment was in place and
operational the captain knew that if
anybody understood the value of
inspection it was bud cindor
yeah so and and Colonel Sidner told me
that story himself when I was doing the
uh for My thesis I did the Sante raid so
I had a chance to interview a lot of the
Sante Raiders
but and I've said before said it was
probably the
best planned rehearsed and Run mission
of all the missions I looked at in my
um
in my thesis even though obviously the
the pows were not at the camp because
the intelligence didn't realize that
they'd been moved earlier
but in the planning and preparation uh
the Green Berets who were running the
same I mean they were inspecting guys
constantly because again that as you
know that was common army mentalities
from from being young Rangers or young
soldiers whether it was Boot Camp or
Ranger school they understood hey you
know we're going to inspect everything
about you before the Sunday Raiders got
on the helicopter
to get ready to go on the mission there
was a guy there going okay how much
ammunition yeah how many magazines do
you have if you've got your water do you
have a radio is it on this frequency you
know every every man before boarding the
helicopter so when we were doing the the
planning for the bin Laden raid I mean
this was constantly in my head and and I
talked to the Ground Force Commander and
I said look you know and of course I'd
known The Ground Force Commander for a
long time I said look I need you
to do this I need to make sure the mass
Chief whoever inspects every single guy
and of course the guys didn't have a
problem getting inspect it they
understood the value of this inspection
and I can't think how many times as a
young officer I was getting ready to go
on a training op or something and at the
last minute you go oh you know I've
forgot my whatever it is you know and uh
I also always made sure that before the
big missions if I was in charge I'm I
would tell the guys I want you ready at
this point
even though we had an hour before we
would get on the bird
and I did that for the bin Laden raid
and I did that for a lot of things
because invariably when you do the
inspection
then all of a sudden somebody goes oh
yeah forgot to bring that okay we'll run
back to your Hooch grab it and get it
because we got time
if all of a sudden you plan the mission
okay we are we are leaving you know the
Garrison at you know 2200
and then all of a sudden 2200 comes and
guys still aren't quite ready then you
the fun Factor all of a sudden it starts
to complicate itself things get harder
and harder
but this idea of inspecting yeah I got
it you know but if you're going to go do
something really complicated you better
spend some time inspecting people and
Sid Noor really understood this and the
story about this this police captain and
I love the line I mean he's telling me
the story over the phone and he said I
told him look if you're a real
professional you'd understand the value
of an inspection and he just said it
casually
and I thought oh that that's golden
because that's what real professionals
understand yeah I I as you're telling
this I'm realizing that such a huge part
of me being a decent seal
was the fact that I had a swim buddy
that you know I went through buds with
and then we did three platoons together
and then we uh three platoon together
then we worked in Chinese all together
and then then I became an officer we
split up but for and we lived together
the whole time so we were roommates but
we inspected each other
without without even without even a word
you're like we we were getting ready for
a dive we'd walk over to each other we
knew what exactly we were getting ready
for a jump we knew he was getting ready
to go to to you know out on a training
up we would just walk over to just we're
guaranteed we're gonna inspect each
other I never forgot anything right at
least never made it past him and ever
you know never paid made it past him as
a buddy but yeah we do that to your
point you know you're getting ready to
go on a dive the dive supervisor or
somebody's gonna expect you you get on
the bird you know it's like check
parachutes you know everybody knows but
for some reason a lot of times getting
ready to go on a lop and if you don't
have somebody that says okay better line
up okay you know who's got the tie ties
how much ammunition you got you got
water you got the radios on this freak
and then I'll sudden you're like yeah
to put batteries in your radios uh yeah
yeah the inspections are helpful yeah
uh next one
communicate communicate communicate and
this is the story that I opened up with
uh with uh Ensign Rambo mcraven on the
on the attack
hey what again what I'd like to really
really like about that story is you
realize how that these you're learning a
lesson in training that's so valuable
and I think that's one of the reasons
that we've been successful is that our
training reflects combat and
what one thing that I remembered about
that when I when I hear communicate
communicate communicate I remember I was
uh going through stt and when we went to
SCT they made you they made us do every
position so you know you might be a
radium in this time you'll be Point man
next time you'd be an aw Gunner this
time and eventually on some long Patrol
I ended up as like rear security
and I had no freaking idea where we were
I had no idea how long I've been walking
for I had no idea where we were going I
I had no idea how long we're going to
take a break for in this perimeter just
didn't know anything was happening and I
was so absolutely irritated by this
that when I moved into a leadership
position I always said to myself I'm
never gonna let anyone feel like I felt
when I was a rear Security on a patrol
so that idea of passing the word and
making sure people understand what's
going on this is so critical and they
you think you're communicating well
you're not you're not you send an email
out right oh I send everyone an email
two weeks ago no they got 47 other
emails that day they didn't open that
email you got to hit them with multiple
times in multiple different directions
but so when I took over Socom
of course as a four-star you know you
get your general officer staff and the
colonels are on the staff and uh and I
would do this I'd say okay guys uh
here's what I want to do I want the
staff do this this and
um so a couple months into the uh into
my command tour I called the staff
together I said uh are you guys making
sure this word gets down to the you know
we had 3 000 people instead oh yes sir
yes sir yes sir I said tell me tell me
how that happens and so I pulled some
kernel aside he said well sir you know
right after I come out of this meeting I
go into my office and I call my uh my
majors in and I tell them what you told
me and then the majors meet with their
people they tell okay okay good good
good
um so that afternoon I go troop the line
so I walked around for a couple hours
and I would just go into various
departments I'd show up you know of
course your little the four
stars area and walk in I'd start talking
to some you know young Sergeant or
something I said
um Sergeant did you hear this
no no sir oh interesting so I kept going
around and just about every young
trooper I talked to so I don't know what
you're talking about okay
so I did kind of this informal survey
and I found out that 75 of the time
the word I was passing just wasn't
getting down so the four-star freaking
that's right so and it took me I mean I
did this over over a period of a couple
weeks kind of doing my own little
assessment so finally a month later I
pulled my staff in again
I said okay boys and girls
let me tell you what I found out and so
I started going through this I said let
me tell you this level of they're not
hearing this at all and of course they
were like well I don't know how why
they're not hearing it you know I'm
passing the word and to your point
boy you got to communicate communicate
communicate I mean up and down the chain
of command and uh and I just found that
it was kind of the classic kids thing
you know you start at one level and
before long the word is either incorrect
or it's not getting past you have to
actively pursue making sure the
information gets down to the rear
security yep and of course I I mentioned
in that one Marshall Lubin who was you
know quite the seal and and one of the
oldest guys that went through training
with me he's the real security for this
particular one and he had no clue what
the hell I was doing Ram Rambo mcraven
was off on his own you know
yeah the uh I don't know how many
companies I've talked to where I've you
know talked to the the c-suite
leadership like oh do you think everyone
knows what's going on there oh yeah of
course we communicate really well and
you go talk to the front line and they
have no idea what's happening I also
often bring up the idea of the 1mc on a
ship which is a very powerful tool and
you you know there's a a microphone that
this commanding officers ship can pick
up and he can talk to every single
person on that ship at one time and
sometimes there's events that happen
there's things that occur that you need
to tell people yourself what's going on
if we had a change in the Rules of
Engagement if we had a a drastic change
in the way we're going to be doing
operations I wouldn't tell the platoon
commanders who could then tell their
platoon Chiefs who could then tell their
lpos who could then tell their squad
leaders who could then tell them what's
going on no I was going to get everyone
into a room and I was going to tell them
what's going on so sometimes got to come
from the horse's mouth well you talk
about the 1mc so because the
communications problems it's so calm
because again uh you've been down there
I mean huge facilities 3 000 people and
the word no matter how hard I tried
wasn't getting down so I put in
essentially a 1mc I put in a PA system
and when I went to my I.T people I said
okay look I want to put a PA system here
and the guy says sir you mean like
Elementary School I said yes whatever it
takes brother we're going to put in a PA
system well it's complicated I mean you
put in speakers all around this massive
building it was not cheap
but at the end of the day every morning
I would get on the the PA system and say
okay hey here's what we're doing today
here's what's going on so-and-so got and
I knew the word would get passed
um and uh and that is that simple little
thing having a public address system
having a 1mc as we called on the ships
as you know is absolutely crucial
everybody on the ship gets the word from
the commanding officer yeah
there you go uh next one
when in doubt overload and this is
something that is in reference to
demolitions and you talk about this in
the book you explain like hey if you're
gonna blow up a obstacle on a beach and
you're trying to figure out how much
demolitions to put on that obstacle the
answer is too much doubling right
because you want to make sure that thing
is gone it's not costing you might maybe
it costs a taxpayer a little something
but it's not costing you anything extra
so you're gonna when in doubt you
overload that with the the metaphor that
you make in here is the amount of work
you are going to put in and you talk
about
well you talk about getting fired yeah
you got fired as uh will you attended
when you got fired
you tried to push something we talked
about this on the last podcast a little
bit you you were trying to change some
things inside of a command and they
weren't the commander wasn't ready to
change those things and so you end up
getting fired
um
and then you also talk about it
um you have an opportunity for a mission
there's you're you're now you're just
taking over Special Operations one of
the Special Operations commands you've
got an opportunity for a mission you you
know the the you take the risk
doesn't go great luckily no one was
killed but it doesn't go great it's not
a good look for you you start to hear
Rumblings about your ability and that's
happened both these times and what you
do is you basically double down on how
freaking hard you're gonna work yeah
this was uh I said early on in my
three-star tour and uh in order to go
into this particular Target which was
not in the country we were supposed to
be in I mean I had to convince everybody
and I spent a couple of months you know
getting centcom approval getting the
Pentagon and secretary's approval and
then going to the White House so I
thought this mission was that important
and there were a lot of people said man
you're you're risking way too much here
and and as you point out uh boys go
across Mission does not go well
fortunately none of our guys were were
killed we had I think a guy winged but
the bad guys we were going after who
we'd hoped to capture we didn't capture
they get killed in the firefight
and uh and then all of a sudden you know
I start hearing remnants well maybe
mcraven's not the right guy for this job
you know I was the first Navy guy to
lead this command so there were a lot of
doubters out there and early on in my
tour
and I remember and and of course when
things like that happen when you know
things don't go well and you put a lot
of effort into it you begin to doubt it
yourself am I the right guy for this job
and I found over the years and it wasn't
just getting fired you know in the
course of a long career you stumble
often
and uh and half of me when I was in
command of Shield team three it happened
to me you know when I was at group one I
mean there are always times when as a as
a leader things don't go well and the
troops sometimes wonder I don't know is
this the guy we wanted leading us and I
always found that the the way to
overcome that and to re-earn the respect
of the troops was to okay now I'm going
to come in earlier than I came in I'm
going to work harder I'm going to stay
later I'm going to come in on the
weekends I'm going to do whatever it
takes
to re-earn the trust of the men and
women that are that you're serving
and I found that nothing kind of
overcomes those problems quite like hard
work uh because you know even if they
don't like it and not everybody liked me
uh they will at some point in time begin
to respect you because you're putting in
the effort
and so like I said this when in doubt
overload again I was a frog man when I
started did a lot of underwater
Demolition and you laid it out perfectly
this was just the nature of the problem
set you know we're gonna we gotta we got
a Japanese Scully uh that uh ought to
take 20 pounds well let's put 40 pounds
on it you know and and you're right the
metaphor is about look uh you got those
hard problems you just double down on
the work
I had uh speaking of getting fired I had
one of my friends get fired and he ended
up you know he there's what what
whatever the dozens of little issues you
have that lead to getting someone fired
my friend got fired and he had to go see
you know the big boss
and he he's calling me from overseas hey
I gotta go see the boss
what should I tell him should I tell him
about this should I tell him about that
should I tell them about the other thing
and I said what you tell him is
you're here because you got fired
because you didn't do a good job and you
want to get better and that's it that's
it that's it that's exactly what he did
and ended up you know on the right path
again but
um yeah that taking ownership of when
you do something and you say yup I
messed that up and
I'm going to work hard and get it fixed
I mean that's all you can do and and to
your point
uh you can't blame somebody else for
your mistake uh it doesn't matter
whether there were other people to blame
or not that's not what leaders do hey if
you were in charge you're responsible
don't don't deflect you know don't
deflect the problem uh don't deflect the
blame you raise your hand you say I'm
responsible I'm gonna get better at it
yeah by the way that was part of it uh
part of it is hey hey buddy
you got fired it's like you know there's
there's this guy might not have a good
personality and that other person might
not have got along this kind of person
might not had the wrong uh concept of
operations for people to be doing and
guess what you weren't able to work all
through that right
so when you tell the boss that's why you
got fired because you messed up it's not
because you're trying to persuade him
that that you're better than you are you
got fired because you messed up right
that's what happened and if you couldn't
get along with your boss over there or
you couldn't get along with the people
your peers and you screwed that up that
is on you it's on your
and say sorry and take ownership and
move on
uh you got this one we already discussed
this one briefly the the can you stand
before the long green table and uh you
have this quote in here you got a bunch
of quotes in here but this one I I kind
of had to read because it's 99 of all
failures come from people who have a
habit of making excuses and that's from
George Washington Carver who was a an
agricultural scientist born into slavery
eventually he became a professor at
Booker T Washington's Tuskegee Institute
who we covered uh Booker T Washington's
book on this podcast Up From Slavery but
99 of all failures come from people who
have a habit of making excuses I wrote a
book called Extreme ownership that is
about not making excuses and you
mentioned the story but I still wanted
to hit it real quick in October of 1925
the nation was fixated on the
court-martial trial of an American hero
General Billy Mitchell Mitchell was a
highly decorated pilot who had received
the nation's second highest award for
Valor for his exploits in aerial combat
during World War one but Mitchell was
also a fierce advocate for air power
believing that another war was on the
horizon and that a unified Air Force
should be built to rival the Army in the
Navy Mitchell was particularly adamant
that airplanes carrying heavy bombs
could sink a battleship however the Navy
leadership and the White House had made
a case to Congress for additional
battleships and defended their position
vehemently to prove their point the Navy
orchestrated several demonstrations of
the battleship survivability but the
exercises were rigged in the Navy's
favor and Mitchell exposed the deception
finally after insisting on a legitimate
test Mitchell proved Beyond a doubt that
air power could dominate on sea and on
land
nevertheless the services fought back
hard against the idea of a unified Air
Force Mitchell was eventually
court-martialed
when he accused the Army and Navy
leadership of almost treasonable
admission administration of the National
Defense that's what Mitchell did yeah
the court-martial had a jury of 13
Military Officers including a young
Major General named Douglas MacArthur
among those who testified on Mitchell's
behalf were a who's who of military
royalty including World War one ace
Eddie rickenbacher General Happ Arnold
General Carl spatz
the latter two officers would go on to
lead the U.S Air Force over the course
of the seven-week trial
Mitchell stood before the long green
table of assembled officers and made his
case he never wavered from his position
that he had a moral legal and ethical
obligation to raise these issues to the
leadership of the Army and the Navy war
was coming he stated and a failure to
recognize the inevitable and plan for
the fight was near treasonous
in spite of all the support he received
and his passionate defense Mitchell was
found guilty on all counts of the
13-member jury MacArthur was the only
officer who voted to acquit he said a
senior officer should not be silenced
for being at variance with his superiors
in rank and accepted Doctrine
seven years later one of Mitchell's
early critics Franklin Delano Roosevelt
became his strongest Advocate by 1942
the Skies over Germany was filled with
American bombers and in 1947 by next
Congress United States Air Force was
established history would reflect that
Billy Mitchell stood tall in the face of
withering criticism and career-ending
threats for his unwavering support of
air power and his principal stand on
Aviation mobilization General Billy
Mitchell would forever be known as the
father of the Air Force
so this is what you talked about earlier
interestingly I I didn't know who Billy
Mitchell was
except for in the book about face
when he is when Colonel hackworth is
getting interviewed he throws it out
there he says in one word you know he
says I wouldn't want it no one wants to
be a Billy Mitchell and that's all he
said and I've eventually looked up this
was years ago I looked up to figure out
who Billy Mitchell was and this is a guy
that you know was ready to stand
um and and do the right thing yeah so as
you mentioned earlier my dad was uh
joined the Army Air Corps in in 1941 and
then served in World War II had a
26-year Air Force career but of course
the Army Air corps became the Air Force
in in 1947 and so I grew up with these
stories about about MacArthur and you
know Truman fire and MacArthur and my
dad always felt that was the right
decision to make MacArthur stepped over
the line didn't support the civilian
leadership but Dad would also tell the
story of Billy Mitchell and uh and his
point to me was in spite of all the
criticism Mitchell received and Mitchell
probably was a little a little too
adamant a little too boisterous but he's
he's so firmly believed uh in this
principle of air power that he was
willing to get court-martialed for it
and my dad used to make the point every
once in a while
you're going to have to stay in your
ground and if you think it is that
important uh stand tall
yes you may get eviscerated for it you
may get fired for it you may get
court-martialed for it
but if it's the right thing to do in the
long run you know you'll be not only
exonerated as Mitchell was in the long
run but people will recognize that you
did the right thing for the right
reasons and again I was fortunate to
grow up with two parents who you know
they taught me all the right lessons
that they had learned you know growing
up themselves
I was getting investigated one time got
investigated a bunch of times but one of
the times I got investigated like I said
part of this because I was always saying
investigate me uh one of the times I got
investigated I I get I get into you know
there's a there's a a Navy Captain I get
called into warcom on a Thursday night
I get called into warcom and there's a
Navy captain
and
it's eight o'clock at night so this
isn't this is not a good time
and so I go in yeah what's going on
um and there's Navy Captain sitting
there and there's an o5 you know
lieutenant or sorry Commander that's his
note taker this is also what is a good
side
and yet at the same time I'm you know it
was like I I'm always ready to stand on
on the the in front of the long green
table
and I sit down I said you know sir
what's going on and he says
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can and will be used
against your court of law he reads Me My
Rights
and so now I'm thinking what is going on
and I said before I respond can can you
just tell me what this is about like I
have no idea what this is about
and he tells me what it's about and I
said you know sir when I joined when I
got to the SEAL Teams
the the people above me in the chain of
command my platoon Chief my platoon
leading petty officer to tell me hey if
you ever get read your rights don't say
another word and get a lawyer
and I said and I've actually told guys
that because that's good advice when you
get read your rights what you should do
is get a lawyer and don't say anything
and I said look in this case what you're
talking about I actually can 100
guarantee you I've done nothing wrong
and I'll waver from White right so you
want me to wave let me sign and I'll
tell you whatever you know I'll tell you
all about this I'm ready to go come
investigate and uh the guy had a really
surprised look on his face and then he
started asking me questions and
eventually he was like gosh well this is
a kind of a crazy uh scenario and I said
good let's you know and so it was you
know it was another time that I got
investigated and and I'm thankful I was
investigated I'm always thankful to be
investigated because then people know
what happened uh but
that I can't I'm glad I don't want have
to I never had to walk into situations
like that thinking they got me you know
my my legitimate mental questions were
what could this possibly be about and
not oh my gosh they got me so well uh as
is the nature of uh of the business
we're in I have also been investigated
many many times and uh and there were
some very senior officers investigating
me and I did the same thing I said look
uh I'm perfectly comfortable with the
decisions I made and yeah and I had a
again interestingly enough while it was
a an overarching
Department of Defense investigation in
one case with a three-star Air Force
General that was the investigating
officer I was a Navy Captain who was a
Jag at the time who came at me pretty
hard
and uh maybe it was the same guy was he
from Socom no he was not he was a
conventional Navy Jag and uh
but right up front I said look yeah I'm
happy to waive my rights and and he was
surprised too because he thought I was
going to lawyer up I said look I am
perfectly comfortable with the decisions
I met were they tough decisions were
they ugly decisions was it all that's
true this is combat things aren't always
as clean as you'd like but I've got I've
I've got you know
no regrets about the decisions I made so
bring it on and for three weeks I mean I
was kind of had the Cleveland lights on
me and guys were and at the end of it uh
it took them about six or seven months
to resolve the investigation and the
three star finally called me
and I was not in Afghanistan at the time
and he calls me up he says hey we have
uh we've completed the investigation
and this was kind of long pause I'm
thinking okay he's about to tell me I'm
going to Leavenworth or something
and he said you know we had a chance to
interview everybody and there were
hundreds of people online he said
he said it's gonna be all right you
actually came out of this looking pretty
good because you you know you did all
the right things I said look you always
try to do the right things you know I
mean it's you don't always do it I mean
sometimes you make them you make bad
mistakes because again we're human but
in this case as ugly as this particular
situation was I knew I had done the best
I could do and I was happy to happy to
you know put it on the record so to
speak
um because that's saying as I mentioned
when I was a young incident can you
stand before the long green table
I always ask myself that and then this
again I can't go into it on this on this
net but suffice to say these are some
tough tough calls but I felt comfortable
in the decisions I was making yeah and
the tough calls that you make you're
making them with the information that
you have that's right which you don't
have the luxury of hindsight you don't
have a crystal ball to know what
happened to what we're wrong you know
and this also goes back to the idea of
covering things up and what happens if
you try and cover things up I know from
life that you can't cover you cannot and
especially in the damn SEAL Teams look
you know the kid that you know when I
was 23 years old and you know whoever
got on a fight down in Coronado on a
Thursday night or a Friday night or a
Saturday night I know we won't tell
anybody everybody knows and so now you
take that into into a combat situation
everybody's gonna know and I I I would
always tell there was a couple uh army
guys and I don't remember all the
details of the story but there's a
couple army guys
early on in the Iraq War
they shot and killed somebody and they
went and planted an AK-47 on that and
they went to jail and I think they I
want to say they got something like 10
years
there's no reason to plant if you're
looking at a street and someone's doing
something they're they're digging a hole
they're they're acting suspicious and
you decide that they're a threat right
you can kill them you can
and and that's okay and you can explain
hey this is what I saw this is the ttps
that they were that they were emulating
or that they were doing this is the
behavior that I saw here's the Rules of
Engagement that I acted within and
here's why I shot a person and they
didn't have a gun and I know that but it
sure looked like they were planning an
idea sure look they would look like they
were passing information it sure looked
like they were spotting for someone else
and that's why I did this and every one
of those the the the Jag would say okay
we we understand what happened
the minute you go out and plant a gun on
somebody just throw everything else out
the window right you just you just
committed a war crime and it's gonna be
bad and that's exactly what happened to
those guys
so the idea of covering something up is
is just it's not going to work it never
works that's right and then to make sure
that you are ready to go stand in front
of the long green table and then on top
of that make sure that everyone that
works for you right knows where you
stand on this because if you start to
give the impression of like well you
know as long as you're kind of staying
within the rules like no we're staying
within the rules this is what's
happening that's what you have to do and
you have to make that clear otherwise
you put yourself in a terrible situation
where you know uh what what is what'd
you say earlier about the West Point I
won't lie cheat steal or tolerate
tolerate those who do
so once you give the indication that
you'll tolerate and somebody does
something that they shouldn't have done
and now you're not going to tolerate it
after the fact you've really screwed
yourself and you screwed that person
right and look that person might have
done something bad that they shouldn't
have done and that's on them but for the
fact that you gave them the impression
that you were going to be okay with that
in any way you also screwed up really
bad and you're putting yourself in just
a terrible situation you know I told
folks in my time in Iraq and Afghanistan
what I tried to do
for the soldier St Louis Airmen marines
that were working for me was to have
bright bright
red lines that said these are the lines
you don't cross
you can do anything you need to within
those lines law of iron conflict comes
into play you know the rules of
engagement come into play but within
this bright red lines you stay in that
lane
and I realized I needed to do that for a
number of reasons one it was the right
thing to do but also what I didn't want
to do
was put these guys in a position where
and you know War can get dark the guys
can go down a very dark bad path when
they start killing the enemy
if they begin to like that too much they
keep moving down this path and they move
outside the bright red lines and then at
the end of the day they will end up
living with that when the war is over
and they'll come back and they'll go
well I did some bad things and uh and I
know that now and then you know In the
Heat of battle sometimes you don't think
about it or you put it down deep and you
you justify it but when the war is over
you come back you're gonna have to bear
that burden and so there were times when
I mean I jacked guys up big time to make
sure that the force understood this is
unacceptable behavior and if I find
anybody doing this you're out of here
and oh by the way if I need to I will
quartz Marshal you
and I fortunately didn't have to do that
often
but and I got a lot of pushback from
guys going you don't understand sir I
mean the Afghans fight like this we need
to stop
these are the law of our this is the law
of arm conflict this is the Rules of
Engagement you are going to stay within
these lines and while the guys weren't
always happy with it I hope at the end
of the day when the dust settles and
they look back they go you know what I
didn't commit a new war crimes I didn't
do anything bad because I was forced to
stay within this box even if it at the
time it didn't seem the right box to be
in I tell leaders sometimes look this is
what's expected of you back to kind of
setting the standards you're right this
is we're never going to cover anything
up you know we're we're never going to
have you know retribution to guys that
come and speak truth to power we're
going to do things that are you know
that are honest and that are within the
rules because if we don't
back to the who's Trident is it the
answer Triton they will reflect poorly
on every person that ever wore a trident
and every person that ever wore an
American flag on their on their shoulder
too don't do it
um but it's hard sometimes you know the
guys are isolated they're out there on
their own
um
and you you gotta as a leader you got to
keep them within those bright red lines
yeah no doubt about that and the the
brighter you make those red lines
the the easier it is for them to see
them the more they know what the
consequences are if they can also bright
red lines that's what you need they
should be definitely afraid of stepping
over those lines otherwise you're gonna
have issues and there and by the way
also they're going to test you yeah
they're gonna brush up against them
they're going to see what happens oh we
and and they're gonna do that and that's
why they you need to be really clear
about this stuff so I really like that
idea of the bright red lines it's
awesome uh the last one of these use is
is something I just talked about always
have a swim buddy
um every frog man knows that in the
turbulent Waters of life you always need
a good swim buddy and you wrap it up
with this find a person you can trust
implicitly be prepared to lean on them
in times of great stress except both
their support and criticism with equal
Grace
be a swim buddy to others
someone out there needs you yeah yeah
having somebody that's going to tell you
how stupid you are
is is a lot more valuable than someone
that's going to tell you oh great you
are great that's right
and and especially I mean I was only a
lieutenant commander so I was many many
miles below you in the chain and I would
have guys being very very nice to me
laughing at my jokes thinking my ideas
were great and I can't even fathom what
it was like for you as a four star uh to
have to to put the oh I was
great every day you don't understand my
jokes were always funny absolutely
brilliant tacticians that's right
strategy oh great Admiral and a Comics
to go
yeah so you got to watch out that's the
swim buddies you want this one buddies
you want are gonna tell you they're
going to be able to rely on them but
you're also going to be able to rely on
them to tell you when you're jacked up
um
I want to close this out the book with a
section that you from the conclusion the
book that you write uh you say this in
his book it worked for me Colin Powell
tells the story of an old General
sitting in the Officers Club who is
approached by a brand new Army second
lieutenant
the general is on his third Martini when
the young Lieutenant gets up the courage
to approach the senior officer
the general is very courteous and after
some small talk the lieutenant finally
asks the question he's been dying to ask
how do you make General the lieutenant
inquires well son the general answers
here's what you do
you work like a dog you never stop
studying you train your troops hard and
take care of them you are loyal to your
commander and to your soldiers
you do the best you can in every Mission
and you love the army
you are ready to die for the mission and
your troops
that's all you have to do
the lieutenant replies wow
and that's how you make General
nah
replies to General that's how you make
first lieutenant
just keep repeating it
and then let them see what you've got
so
there you have it that's all it takes
that's it but you know that's uh it's a
great story that and I got to be close
friends with General Powell secretary
Powell before he passed for the last
couple years and and he would tell that
story occasionally and then he had it in
one of his books and I thought it was
very emblematic of what we know as
Leaders as I mentioned earlier on you
know you got to bring it every single
day and I don't care whether you're an
Ensign or a four-star Admiral or whether
you're a semen recruit or a master chief
you bring it every single day you got to
work hard you got to take care of your
troops you got to lead from the front
you have to do all these sort of things
every single day
not Monday Wednesday and Friday you know
not Tuesdays and Thursdays but every
single day and you won't you won't bring
it every day you know because we're
human we got bad days
but those days you don't bring it you
ought to be a little sick to your
stomach and say I didn't bring it
today I'm gonna have to bring it even
more tomorrow
and yeah it's hard it's hard every
single day uh but you've got the honor
of leading
you know great Soldier St Louis Urban
Marines civilians whatever it is
remember it's an honor to be in a
leadership position
um every day you got to do that that's
how you make first lieutenant second
Lieutenant yeah and as I read that I'm
just thinking about you and thinking
about what you've done in your career
and and and how that's that's literally
what you did
um
you know and what you just said I I
wrote about one of my books uh it's
called leadership strategy and tactics I
wrote about that I I you know pulled my
radio man aside when I was platoon
coming I said Hey listen you're the most
important guy in this platoon because if
we get into a firefight something
happens
you're going to be the guys to be able
to call for help
and then I talk to the machine gunner
and I said listen
you're the most important guy in this
platoon because we get into a gunfight
you're gonna be putting down suppressive
fire that's going to allow us to
maneuver and and either take out the
enemy or get away from the enemy
and then of course I talked to you know
the corpsman and I said hey Doc you know
the most important guy in this platoon
because if someone gets wounded you're
gonna be the one that's gonna save their
life and this goes on and obviously what
I was telling everyone in the tune that
they're the most important person to
platoon and what made me think of that
is as you're talking about whether
you're you know a bm2 or or a semen
Apprentice or you're a private first
class or you're a individual contributor
at a company what you're doing inside of
an organization number one you're a
leader you are a leader no matter where
you are inside of an organization
but also what you do has a huge impact
and the the more you work and the better
you TR the more you try to do a good job
the more positive impact you will have
on that organization and ultimately the
mission and ultimately all that will
come back
to you and you'll be able to get
promoted and when you get promoted guess
what you get to do you get to take care
of more people more work that's right
get to take care of more people and
that's what it's about and uh yeah
leadership the hardest of human
Endeavors and that is why it is the most
rewarding of human Endeavors
um
I don't know that gets us up to speed I
think that's the book like like I said I
I hit the wave tops of some of the book
books outstanding uh Echo Charles yes
sir do you have any questions yes I do
oh here we go actually that last part
kind of reminded me of this question
that I was wondering um how do I become
Admiral
you know there's a uh
there's another story at the end of the
book and uh it's from Stephen
pressfield's Gates of Fire
and uh you know for your listeners you
know Gates fire it's a fictional account
of the the 300 Spartans at Thermopylae
and of course talks about you know
Xerxes the great uh 480 BC sweeps cross
Asia Minor
um comes to the to the borders of Greece
and the 300 Spartans move to Thermopylae
where they're gonna they're gonna hold
the pass well they hold it for three or
four days till every one of them is
killed but one guy
and and in reality the truth of the
matter is the Persians continue on into
Greece but they frankly frankly so
exhausted from the fight at thermopoly
eventually they get beaten and they
retreat but on their way out as
pressfield tells the story
he's got the single Spartan and he
brings the Spartan to him and of course
King Leonidas was the king of the
Spartans and he led the fight at
Thermopylae and so Xerxes brings the
Spartan in and he says do I mean he
wants to know why did they fight so hard
for King Leonidas what was it about the
king that made them prepared to to
sacrifice their lives for him and the
quote goes something like this you know
that the the king does not abide in his
tent
while his men bleed and die on the
battlefield
the king does not dine while his men go
hungry nor asleep while his men stand
watch upon the wall the king does not
earn the respect of his men through fear
or the price of gold
the king earns their love through the
sweat on his back and the pain he
endures on their behalf
the king is the first to lift the
heaviest burden and the last to put it
down
and I think you know to answer your
question if you want to get to the top
be the guy that picks up the heaviest
burden first
and puts it down last yeah that's how
you make
the next rank that's how you make First
losing that's how you make first
lieutenant so that process in the can
like do you have to be in the Navy to be
Admiral or like how does that I don't
know
so it's actually part of part of why I
said why how can I because let's say I
just joined the military and I'm like
hey one day I want to be like Admiral
you know is there a special that's a
good question here's what I told you I'm
saying yeah it's interesting because uh
you know when I joined the SEAL Teams
back I went through buds in 77 and 78 I
joined the teams there were no Admirals
you know there were only two Navy
captains so that's like an army colonel
right nobody when I came in nobody had
any expectation of being an admiral
nobody had any expectation to be a Navy
Captain because there were only two of
them one on the east coast at group two
and one of the West Coast at group one
all I wanted to do was be a seal platoon
Commander and I think the Colin Powell
story is pretty important because it is
I mean I got the underwater demolition
team 11 and this was my task to be the
best instant I could be at UDT 11. and
then from there I went on and everywhere
you went it's like I'm just gonna do the
best job I can right here
look too far down the road it was just
like hey this is my job now be the best
I can be and after a while I call them
Powell's Story show them what you got
and you know you'll get promoted you
keep moving
what does concern me about you know the
the Special Operations Community today
is guys can come in and they can be
four-star Admirals and they can be
four-star generals
and I want to make sure that those
people that are thinking about that boy
that better not be your thought when
you're going to Seal training or ranger
training your thought ought to be how
can I be the best petty officer I can be
today how can I be the best instant I
can be today how can I be the best
Sergeant whatever it has do the best you
can where you're at and then show them
what you got yeah so as you get promoted
up the ranks you're promoted essentially
above others though right like do people
like there's a competition are they
compete yeah exactly sure yeah there is
a competition you know I was fortunate
so when I went through my peers or all
of us none of us expected to make flag
officer in fact I don't think most of us
expected to make Navy Captain we were
all very close friends and we stay close
friends today and so there was never
this sort of you know backstabbing you
know we all were thankful that we got as
far as we did we were all appreciative
when somebody else you know made made
flag before we did or when everybody
else was successful it was a great
environment to grow up in because
you know it was we were friends before
we were competitors and that friendship
held ground and today I remain
tremendous friends with whether it's
Admiral Eric Olson Emerald Joe McGuire
Admiral Joe Kernan uh you know Ed
Winters Bob Harward the list goes on and
on they're all flag officers that uh you
know we all grew up together but yes to
answer your question there's a board
yeah but not only one person comes out
so you know when you make Lieutenant
Commander there's you know 20 30 guys
make Lieutenant command or whatever but
then as the pyramid gets smaller and
smaller next rank fewer guys make it
next rank fewer guys make it next rank
so when I made Admiral
uh that year I was the only seal that
made one star
um and then we kind of picked up one
Admiral every year after that sort of
thing gotcha so let's say for example
like E4 let's say to become an E5 that's
not the case right because everyone can
kind of become E5 right and then as you
go up then it starts to kind of diminish
as far as like yeah but but even in the
illicit ranks I mean it gets small I
mean to make cheap petty officer so you
know yeah uh from an E3 to an E6 you
know and then all of a sudden you're
gonna be a chief petty officer well that
that's still a pyramid and it gets it
gets smaller and smaller okay yeah that
that being said there's people that are
getting out there's people that don't
want to get promoted there's people that
are just you know they're they're
getting out of 20 years they're getting
out you know a lot of a lot of seals get
out at 20 years okay so they get out
there's that means a bunch of people
yeah a bunch of bunch of openings you're
gonna get but um do you get a bigger
house when you become Admiral yeah you
do actually right on yeah yeah there you
go but uh but the interesting thing
about it is it's a bit of a gilded cage
because uh so the house the first house
I had when I was a one star was out of
Fort Bragg because I was on an army base
and and we and frankly it wasn't I mean
it was just a standard Army house but I
was gone all the time so it really
didn't make a difference but when I came
back as a three star uh now I was
actually going to be the senior guy
there at Fort Bragg and so the base
commander calls me I said sorry we got a
big house where I said no no I want the
old house I was in but sir we got this
other figure I said I understand I I
like the old house yeah sir but that's
that's kind of where the June I said
okay brother maybe you don't understand
this my wife and I want to move back
into that old house uh but yeah you know
there's there are perks but again as we
were talking the perks really mean
nothing I mean at the end of the day the
more senior you get the expectation from
yourself ought to be that means I've got
more people to lead means you got to
work harder
um people are from the outside they see
the perks
but you realize pretty quickly that
those are just window dressing um
great to see you again yeah good sitting
here thanks sir any closing thoughts no
you know Jocko as always uh appreciate
you having me on uh you know as I uh
I've mentioned before you do a
remarkable job not just of on the
podcast and the books but of
representing
the seal Community I'm incredibly proud
of you I was talking to Jim Worthington
last night who you remember well a chief
petty officer we were he didn't know
that I was coming today we got talking
about the time when we were setting up
Quantum Leap and we had the Blue Force
trackers and you guys were on your way
up to Miramar or something he's telling
the story he goes so Jocko was my radio
Mentor I think at the time or something
like this and uh and I gotta laughing
thinking man that's that's been a few
years ago but uh but I'll tell you
everywhere you have been Jocko you have
represented the community with
Incredible dignity incredible honor you
personify every single leadership
quality that is in this book and in your
book
um so let me tell you it's a it's an
honor to spend a little time with you
well sir I appreciate that uh obviously
uh you need to do a little bit more
research about me
um hey for me the honors all mine and
and I'll tell you I went to the Seal
Team One 60th anniversary a few months
ago and what struck me was you know
there's all the old old guys from Seal
Team One the Vietnam guys
but when I was a young seal I went to
the 30th anniversary
so I went to the 30th Anniversary now 30
years later I'm going to the 60th
anniversary and it's just it you know
when you think about the tradition of
the SEAL Teams it's not that old like
every one of those Admirals that you
just rattled off I know every single one
of them that's kind of crazy right the
fact that you know I'm sitting here
talking to you and we both worked with
Double L Jones like these are these are
crazy things and the community is just
so small and yet
um has had a big impact and and for me
you know I always say I try and give
back what I can to the teams because the
teams gave me everything so
um I know you feel the same way
absolutely honor to have you on here
thanks for uh sharing the wisdom of the
bullfrog with us all thanks for your
leadership and the teams the Navy and
Special Operations thanks for your
leadership for the country
you made an incredible impact on on our
community I mean you think about we've
been around for 60 years you've been you
around for 37 of those years and I'm not
just trying to make you feel old uh but
that that really is incredible and um
we're grateful for your service for your
sacrifice and for your leadership always
thank you sir it was an honor thanks
Jaco
and with that Admiral bill mcraven has
left the building
just a real honor to have him on here
and
you know as he was leaving 37 years he
was in Seal team's only been around for
60. yeah that's that's most of it that's
you know legit and all those Lessons
Learned I'm glad he's capturing this
information
solid advice simple advice and as the
cover of the book says simple but not
easy which is actually in the book
extreme ownership same thing just
talking about leadership in there simple
not easy which I actually in the book
extreme ownership a tribute
to Dean Lister
I attribute the quote simple not easy to
Dean Lister because that's the first
person I heard say it oh when you're
doing Jiu Jitsu and you get caught in
this position you got to move this you
got to move your hips over here it's
very simple it's not easy yeah but it's
simple he does say that a lot too yes
and it's it's often very true and that's
what this book is about you know
leadership Made Simple not easy
it's not that hard you know what's right
that's the way many worthwhile things
are in life so it makes them valuable
right is that they're simple they're not
easy if they were easy as they say
everyone would do it
but I like constant
the constant work that it takes to
become better mentally and physically
everybody kind of knows like let's face
it you could go and uh you could go on
the internet and look up eight million
different workout programs that are
various levels of complexity or you
could just start lifting weights yeah
doing squats and you'd be getting
stronger just just like that well you
know one of the tried and true protocols
for lifting is that's still even today
this was like I don't even know when it
was in invented or introduced or
whatever it's the five by five just five
six or five yeah yeah for sure simple
simple not always easy not always easy
by the way
the questions you were asking at the end
yes they were way out they were way out
of bounds no no no no like you asking
bounce no no no no it made me realize
how little you know about the military
oh okay I didn't think when you asked
the Admiral the four-star Advil yes sir
the commander the former commander of
all Special Operations in the United
States of America the most powerful
country in the world if you asked him if
do you have to be in the Navy to be an
animal
should I I might as well just say do I
have to be in the military to be an
admiral that would have been just that
would have been a similar question be
saying do you have to do do you have to
do Jiu Jitsu to be a black belt in Jiu
Jitsu okay that's kind of a similar
question
look
you you know a lot about a lot of
different stuff sure even though you you
know you there's some things you don't
know about but you know a lot about a
lot of stuff
I didn't realize how much you did not
know especially after you've been
listening to this particular podcast for
382 episodes by the way well and to say
Hey sir in order to be an admiral do you
have to be in the Navy
well hey look no I don't want to split
hairs here but technically my question
was how do I become an admiral which
could technically be even more ignorant
because yes Echo you cannot be an
admiral but that was more of an
expression like hey if I'm a person who
I'm not in the military yet I'm 18 19
whatever you know how do I become
Admiral in the event of me wanting to
become an admiral where and actually his
answer was even better than I expected
his answer was he took a crap question
and turned it into a freaking
outstanding answer he totally did hey I
want to review the tapes all that
because I think if we drill down and
capture his expression when you're
asking that question I think he might
have thought you were joking I was
almost like wait is what's echo is he
trying to be funny what is going on here
and he took your junk question no
offense sure hey can we look back and
say it was kind of a junk question
um I I can't refute that okay he took
that I gave an epic answer yeah he's got
to give even a little extra credit for
the Admiral today oh big time and and
the idea too that even it had a lot to
do with actually essentially the same
thing as becoming a general right what
he was talking about earlier where it's
like hey you just do you know yeah
be awesome worker I wasn't just keep
showing up it was like work hard make
sacrifice be ready to die like there's a
lot of stuff in Colin Powell's answer
yeah and then he just went straight to
leonidy's answer yeah well he was and
you know what do you say something every
day right uh bring it everything yeah
yeah exactly right so and so that kind
of to me translated 100 over to the
whole black belt thing well especially
when I ask the question so when I'm like
Hey how do I become Admiral the thing is
you don't ask you don't come into Jiu
Jitsu ideally from an ideal standpoint
you don't say you know I'm gonna
you don't do that you just go and learn
Jiu Jitsu you get a white belt you get
it you know and you essentially approach
it the exact same way that's gonna be
the best it's hard to argue that that's
going to be the best way to do it so
it's like that big parallel right yeah
and it's a another parallel is like in
Jiu Jitsu don't worry about getting
promoted don't ask about getting
promoted how do you get promoted at work
don't ask about getting promoted don't
say hey when can I get promoted just
work hard and and eventually it'll come
your way and that's the the basic
concept from Colin Powell and then the
basic concept from the Admiral as well
uh but yeah I want to review the tapes
we'll see if he didn't if he doesn't
give you at least a little bit of a
smirk or something I'd be I'd be even
more impressed yeah no even more
impressive
I don't I can't read his mind but put it
this way if he thought I was joking in
hindsight
I would not be surprised yeah I think I
was even I I mean I know you pretty well
and even I was like wait a second does
he have a follow-up is there some comedy
thing that's about to go down is there
some deep philosophical path and it
turns out no no I know
all right no I but I was for real
wondering about that because you know
like what did you actually mean by this
okay so overall how do I become an actor
okay so it might have to be in the Navy
if I had a bunch of time if you remember
I kind of like threw that in like hey
let me make sure I have this right
almost kind of thing that was the whole
thing about do you have to be in the
Navy I figured
like bro I don't know this stuff but so
no no the whatever the whole
comprehensive question
in a nutshell if that even makes sense
was kind of like you know how like if
you want to be mayor or Governor or
judge or whatever like you got to do
certain things first then you kind of
got to get elected and all this stuff
there's like a this kind of zigzag
process that goes on you know where
you know in certain companies for
example you start out in the mail room I
don't know this arbitrary
um start in the mail room then you move
up then you move up and you just work
hard work hard work hard and then you
move up and then you're not on a CEO
whatever kind of a thing it's more
linear you know yeah or it's actually
pretty linear in the military as well in
in the Navy yeah like you get
commissioned as an officer then and you
could track the career for like what a
pilot does like oh you become a pilot
then you become a whatever then you
become a squadron commander or a
squadron Ops and you come a squadron XO
then you become a squadron commander
then you become and you go up right if
you're in this in the Navy for the for
the SEAL Teams you become an assistant
platoon Commander a platoon Commander a
troop Commander an Ops officer an
executive officer a commanding officer a
major commander and then an admiral yeah
so there is actually a progression yeah
yeah okay so that's perfect right there
so you don't like you don't become this
get promoted to this position and then
you got to kind of run for Admiral where
people gotta vote for you or nothing
like that although although people
actually kind of do vote for you because
you'll be up on a on a selection board
and there might be four people that are
up for Admiral and the other Admirals
are voting on it like okay yeah like you
know Echo has been just a stellar combat
leader and he's been in charge of uh oh
yeah you know a major command and he's
been interested let's pick him so they
are actually essentially dude they do
vote on you okay I got it okay yay I see
perfect right there see us like me uh
you know I don't know that kind of stuff
I do now now you know another uh one
last expression that I'm that I'm gonna
bring with me as well is um using the
expression wire brush yeah
he came out of the gate with that one
too yeah and he used it again too I was
like oh bro I need to roll that into my
everyday vocabulary well what's
interesting is in the Navy that is a
very specific thing right like you're
gonna be of the normal Navy person is
gonna have much more chances of
literally use utilizing a wire brush and
in the SEAL Teams you get a wire brush
to clean out your UDT life jacket and
keep it all squared away usually wire
brush on your weapon you like you
legitimately will use a wire brush yeah
but I like the fact that it transfers
even to a civilian that doesn't even
know that you need to be in the Navy to
be an admiral still understands the wire
brush up and down my left side we know
how that's going to feel we know how
it's going to feel I got it you know
it's not going to be a good feeling you
don't like it uh okay lots of Lessons
Learned speaking of wire brush doesn't
feel good you know it does feel good
what lifting yes sir doing Jiu Jitsu
good training you're getting good you're
kind of kind of getting back in the game
over here on on your side Echo Charles I
would say we are back for sure
um you know what it was what are those
conscious things and actually you've
helped me like actually I even told you
this already but you helped me a lot
where like you'll
I used to like ju I used to for like a
better way of putting it
I get reminded that hey Echo you
actually do Jiu Jitsu did you know that
you know kind of a thing when you'd post
pictures or you know this kind of stuff
or whatever be like freaking that's oh
it's too late you know and the days that
I would make it it'd be like right in
the middle of something and it flashes
to me hey wait if I left like in five
minutes I could make the training you
know that's when I would make it but now
since it's more on my mind you're always
reminding me and I'm like oh yeah and
then you go a few times and you're like
okay that's part of the schedule now
yeah oh yeah I even rolled the kids in
brother going you know so I was like it
was just that one small teeny tiny thing
like it was almost like her all I needed
was a reminder just need that reminder
to get back on the master we're back on
the mats now we're back we need the fuel
you know get yourself some Jocko fuel go
to jockoffuel.com get yourself some pink
lemonade which I'm drinking right now
pink lemonade
just delicious energy in a can that's
what you need
get some go get some I just by the way
as soon as the Admiral left I pounded a
banana milk yeah RTD ready to drink yeah
let's go down real quick too by the way
um my kids now
prefer the banana okay yeah I don't have
them at home but we got them from here
uh check it out well you can get this
stuff at Wawa
bottom right for the energy drink why
because we're getting a little bit we're
taking some abuse from some of the big
companies but you can also get the stuff
at Vitamin Shop number one brand of
vitamin shop
military commissaries we're working on
the exchanges everybody for the military
exchanges Hannaford Dash stores wake
foreign ShopRite Circle K in Florida HEB
Meyer
by the way crushing crushing admire
crushing an HEB everybody that's down
and down in Tejas everybody that's up in
in the in the mire a of operations thank
you for going out there and getting
after it uh go get this stuff
jocofuel.com if you don't have it near
you you can order get yourself some time
War as well this is
this is something I will be taking for
the rest of my life and the reason is
because look do you feel better yes you
do did I notice
documented Improvement in my eyesight
yeah yes I did that's crazy right that's
crazy
and and now like I'm noticing it all the
time so
I will be taking time more for the rest
of my life so check that out as well it
is uh got all the vitamins that you need
the minerals that you need and some
anti-aging some ocular nutrition in
there it's just freaking awesome so
check that out drfield.com there you go
also urgent USA American made stuck
jeans boots
and when I say American made again I'm
gonna say it again it's not just
assembled in America not just um put the
tag on it at the end in America from
like the cotton grown
America
the buttons they make that they put on
the G America
from the material
all the way to the end product anyway
it's a big deal though you know
economically uh you don't support
slavery and you think that oh yeah we
don't have to say no we we exported the
slavery yes we did and now it's still
going though still going we don't
they're slavery right now there's
slavery right now and if you're wearing
something that's made in China you're
supporting slavery right now as we speak
so don't do it get something made in
America in America it's true so there
you go origin USA good geez get rash
guards get jeans get boots get whatever
you need got training shorts now
I'm wearing them the new training shorts
they're good to go all right there you
go it's true also jacob.com
originusa.com also Jacob is a store
called Jocko store
jockostore.com is where you can get your
discipline equals Freedom shirts hoodies
hats
that lightweight hoodie is coming in
real Handy right now Springtime it's
that time of year it's that in between
our weather it's insane well in
California I don't know I don't know
everybody's in different spots so I
don't know we have a heavier weighted
goodies too so all good
um uh check that out there's a a t-shirt
subscription scenario you get a new
shirt every month the the designs go a
little bit outside the red line
sometimes oh but appropriately no not
the red line Sorry the um
what do you call it if you ain't trying
okay so you're you're pushing the
envelope we're thinking outside the box
a little bit on that one yes but well
within the red lines yes you that's a
good point because it's true we don't we
don't uh we don't defy the hard set
boundaries of the path we don't not with
these designs anyway people seem to like
them Jocko store.com checked that out if
you like uh subscribe to the podcast uh
subscribe to Jocko underground Jocko
underground.com we're putting out
another little podcast talking about
things that will help you in life
curiosity overcoming little challenges
we're answering a bunch of questions we
answer all the questions that come in I
think we're on question
uh or 400 300 something like that so we
we answer questions on that Jocko
underground.com it costs 8.18 cents a
month if you can't afford it it's okay
email
assistance.underground.com we'll take
care of you but this is how we protect
ourselves from being shut down off of a
platform we don't own this platform
we own Jocko underground.com will always
be on there
putting the word out
so check that out check out our YouTube
check out psychological warfare check
out flipsidecanvas.com check out the
books wisdom of the bullfrog
by Admiral William H mcraven you heard
us review the the wave tops of it today
there's all kinds of really awesome
stories in there and awesome knowledge
check out the rest of his books as well
you can find them on our on our website
um check that out for sure and then of
course I've written a bunch of books
some of them about leadership some are
about laundromats by the way got a book
called final Spence about a laundromat
kinda I've written a bunch of kids book
kids books get those kids books if you
know a kid between under the age of 14
between 0 and 14 immediately right now
go and get these books go to Warrior
kid.com and just get all these books for
these children
there's literally nothing better you
could do for them
nothing go get in these books
also get Mikey and the dragons check out
about face by David hackworth you heard
me mention it today a couple times
extreme ownership the dichotomy of
leadership we also have a leadership
consultancy called Echelon front go to
nationalfront.com if you need help
inside your organization we have an
online Training Academy because
leadership training is not an
inoculation a leadership book doesn't
teach you how to how to lead in one
sitting
you need to actually train it just like
going to the gym
so go to extreme ownership.com learn how
to live your life
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families or Goldstar families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization if you want
to donate or you want to get involved go
to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
and also don't forget about Micah Fink
who is up there currently latest report
he is wearing a bare skin
and he is stalking a giant elk
so he only has by the way a twig that he
sharpened up on a rock but he's up there
Heroes and horses dot org he's taking
veterans and helping them find
themselves if you want to connect with
us on social media
you can you can Echo is adequate Charles
I am at Jocko willing just just be
careful because it's not just us on
there there's a whole algorithm on there
a monster algorithm that will try and
grab you and try and get your time from
you get your attention take you off the
path
algorithm is just a big baseball bat
that's trying to knock you off the path
it's true so watch out for that and uh
thanks once again to Admiral mcraven for
joining us
sharing his lessons learned and most
important thanks to the Admiral for his
selfless
37 years of service and sacrifice to our
great nation
and thanks to all the military men and
women out there right now who tonight as
we speak
are serving and protecting
our country from those who seek to
destroy it and also thanks to police and
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
EMTs dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thank you for what you do
every day to keep us safe here at home
and everyone else out there let's
remember what the Admiral wrote
when he put in words the day you no
longer believe you have something to
prove the day you no longer believe you
must give it your all the day you think
you are entitled the special treatment
the day you think all your hard days are
behind you is the day you are no longer
the Right leader for the job
and I'll take that one step further that
day
that day when you feel entitled and you
feel special and you feel like you don't
have to give it everything you've got
that is the day you start to die
so don't let that happen
don't stop fighting don't stop striving
don't stop working
and no matter what
don't stop getting after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out